Das war tatsächlich der Vorteil von Fritz. Es gab einen festen Termin, da musste es losgehen und die Technik hat funktioniert, wenn nicht hat man eine vielstellige Telefonnummer gewählt. Und damit herzlichen herzlichen willkommen zum 256. Chaos Radio, fast live aus der Marienstraße 11. Ich will gar nicht so genau beschreiben, was ja das passiert ist, dass diese Sendung möglich gemacht hat. Aber wenn ihr sie hört, ist es immerhin ein unumstößlicher Beweis dafür, dass es passiert ist und dass wir möglicherweise wichtige Dinge erklären. Es geht heute um etwas, das klingt wie entweder eine politische Partei, die einmal die Gründung verpasst hat oder eine gefährliche Krankheit, PSD2. Dazu begrüße ich recht herzlich Henrik, hallo und guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag. Aus Berlin.
Und aus Saarbrücken, Mutags. Hallo und guten Tag.
Hallo.
So, warum sprechen wir mit PSD2? Das witzige ist, als ich erfahren habe, es gibt da etwas, wo man sprechen kann, habe ich mich gefragt, was ist das, worum geht es da, habe ich irgendwas mit Banken, dass der Online-Banking irgendwie neu ist, das sind Ausflug davon, und dann habe ich festgestellt, ich habe keinerlei Berührungspunkte damit anscheinend. Hat sich dann das falsch herausgestellt, dann habe ich lange nachgedacht, dann hatte ich so, doch, was mir in letzter Zeit aufgefallen ist, ist, dass irgendwann, ich habe gar nicht genau mitbekommen, wann ist das Online-Banking bei mir auf fünf Minuten runtergegangen. Wenn man sich einloggt, was man sozusagen, also du loggst dich ein und versuchst, was zu machen, suchst dann irgendwie die Unterlage, die dir noch fehlt, um die Banküberweisung aufzuholen, dann kommst du zurück an deinen Computer und das sagt, wir haben dich ausgeloggt, denn du warst zu lange weg. Das hat mit PSD2 zu tun. Und PSD2 heißt an dem zufolge auch?
Die Payment Services Directive, und zwar schon die zweite Version.
Ich kann euch nicht mehr hören.
Es ist also eine EU-Verordnung? Was heißt das nochmal? Eine EU-Verordnung? Das ist, die EU erlässt was und das muss dann in regionale Gesetze?
Genau, die PSD2 ist 2015, glaube ich, erlassen worden und musste dann zwei Jahre später, das heißt 2017, in Nationales Recht überführt werden. Wurden gewesen sein. Das ist dann die Zahlungsdienste-Umsetzungsgesetz, oder so ähnlich in Deutschland.
Und ist dann wann in Kraft getreten, tatsächlich?
September, also in Kraft getreten ist natürlich sofort. Aber die meisten Dinge haben aber eine Übergangsregelung. Und wirklich schlimm, wenn man das so bezeichnen dürfte, war der 14. September 2019.
Okay, das heißt, das ist so ein bisschen wie bei der DSGVO gewesen, also der Datenschutzgrundverordnung. Alle wussten oder alle hätten weit vorher wissen können, da kommt etwas auf uns zu. Und dann waren alle total überrascht, so wie die Bahnen im Winter, dass es schneit.
Ja, sie waren aber schon ein bisschen früher überrascht. Denn es gab noch mehrere Vorfristen, zu denen bestimmte Dinge hätten fertig sein sollen müssen und nicht fertig gewesen worden sind. Einige sind jetzt noch nicht fertig. Das heißt, ja, sie waren nicht so sehr überrascht, sondern sie waren alle weniger. Langenhalten konzertiert. Weniger wie die Bahn im Winter, als mehr wie die Bahn vor dem Ende des Gleises.
Du bist ja heute hier, weil du Experte in dem Thema bist. Und zwar aus allen Perspektiven.
Genau, ich bin sowohl als Privatperson betroffen, also ähnlich wie du, bloß ein bisschen mehr. Ich habe aber auch noch eine Firma, die ich leite. Wir haben Firmenkonten, ich habe ein paar Vereine, bei denen ich mich ums Konto kümmere. Dann hab ich noch eine Familie mit Familienkonto. Ich habe durchgezählt, ich komme, glaube ich, auf neun verschiedene Banken, bei denen ich unterschiedliche Konten unterhalte.
Okay, und da kommt man in eine Berührung. Aber du hast auch sozusagen dir Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie man damit umgeht, wenn man Dinge programmieren oder nutzen möchte.
Ich bin ein PSD2-Entwickler, also auf der anderen Seite bin ich auch noch.
Mutags, warum bist du eigentlich hier? Weil ich frustriert bin. Wovon bist du frustriert?
Außerdem bin ich gar nicht da. Na, ich hab so ein bisschen auch das Problem, dass diese ganzen Umstellungen halt das Online-Banking kaputt gemacht haben. Die ganzen Bekannten so rundherum waren nur noch am Schimpfen, alle ausgesperrt aus dem Online-Banking. Und da liest du irgendwie auf Twitter, dass da irgendwie die Empöre ja losgeht und es ist alles schlimm.
Also, das müsst ihr mir tatsächlich mal ein bisschen erklären, weil ich hab, also du hast einen Vortrag auf dem 36. Chaos Communication Congress gehalten, den hab ich mir auch angehört. Und da hast du sehr viele Dinge erzählt, die wir auch gleich noch berichten werden. Und ich fand das aber ganz witzig, weil ich so wenig in Kontakt damit bin. Weil ich habe ein Online-Konto, na ja zwei, aber eins sozusagen, was ich sozusagen so benutze, dass es mich im Alltag irgendwie tangiert, wenn das passiert. Und da war irgendwann mal vor, also kann letztes Jahr auch ein bisschen Zeit gewesen sein, so hier, wir müssen jetzt mal deine TAN-App und du musst jetzt deine ITAN-Liste wegschmeißen. Aber das war für mich so, na ja, manchmal ändern sich halt Dinge, das ist schon okay. Und ansonsten habe ich nie was damit zu tun gehabt. Also zum Beispiel in der Anmoderation zu dem Chaos-Vortrag, die Holger klein gemacht hat, sagte er, ja, ich habe so eine App, die darf auf meine Konten zugreifen. Und die sagt auf einmal, sie darf das nicht mehr. Was ist da los? Das ist auch der Grund. Und ich habe das so was nie gemacht. Da war ich wie so ein alter Mann. Es gab schon sehr lange dieses Sofort-Überweisungen, wo ich habe das einmal ausprobiert mit so einem interessierten Grauen. Und habe festgestellt, ah, das funktioniert so, ein Dienst greift. Will mein Passwort fürs Online-Banking haben? Und dann war ich so, nein, nein, das will ich lieber nicht. Und von daher bin ich nicht so richtig tangiert gewesen von diesem Ding. Und auch wenn Mutags jetzt gerade erzählt, alle fluchen, habe ich das irgendwie gar nicht mitbekommen. Trifft das jetzt nur bestimmte Leute? Oder was außer diese 5-Minuten-Regelungen kommen noch daher, die jetzt, die man im Alltag mitbekommen hätte?
Naja, du hast jetzt neuerdings, du kannst deine alten Sicherheitsmedien nicht mehr verwenden, sondern die Tann-Liste giltet nicht mehr. Also komplett gestrichen Tann-Listen. SMS ein bisschen nicht mehr. Du musst jetzt eine App oder einen anderen sogenannten dynamischen Authentifikator benutzen. Dynamisches Sicherheitsmerkmal.
Dynamisch heißt in dem Fall Dinge, die das irgendwas generiert wird?
Genau, und dass es an die Transaktion gebunden ist.
Okay, also es wird nicht im Vorhinein generiert, sondern erst wenn ich sage, ich will das machen.
Genau, und zwar in Bezugnahme auf zum Beispiel die Kontonummer des Empfängers. Aber umgekehrt ist es nicht immer so. Es gibt neuerdings Ausnahmen. Ich habe das in meinem Vortrag Surprise SCA genannt, also SCA heißt Strong Customer Authentication, das ist dieser neue Mechanismus. Du musst halt jetzt manchmal eine TAN eingeben, wenn du dich beim Online Banking anmeldest. Also nicht immer, nur manchmal. Bei Überweisungen musst du auch nur, also meistens eine TAN eingeben, aber nur manchmal.
Das klingt noch nicht nach dollem Ärger.
Du kannst es jetzt nicht mehr vorhersehen.
Das ist doch aber nur teilweise korrekt. Das ist ja das Problem. Also es gibt ja durchaus Banken, die haben das anders implementiert. Bei der DKB zum Beispiel, die wollen immer eine TAN haben beim Login, weil sie es eben einheitlich machen wollen, dass es nicht mal mit TAN und mal ohne ist.
Genau, die Richtlinie dahinter ist nämlich, dass du als Bank erlauben darfst, keine TAN zu verwenden, wenn der Zugriff auf Kontoinformationen weniger als 90 Tage. Der Nachteil als Kunde ist erstmal die fehlende Vorhersehbarkeit. Du weißt im Vorhinein nicht, muss ich meinen TAN-Generator rausholen. Ich habe das in meinem Vortrag beschrieben. Ich habe dann so am 14. 15. September das erste Mal auf meiner Banking-App, wo ich alle, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Konten das sind bei den Banken, so einmal auf alle aktualisieren gedrückt. Und dann kam es halt an mit acht verschiedenen Tans auf vier oder fünf verschiedene Modalitäten. Also einige kommen dann halt mit der Chiptan. Die habe ich halt, früher war Chiptan das Medium, was man haben wollte.
Chiptan ist das, wo man so ein extra Gerät hat, wo man eine Karte reinsteckt?
Genau. Die gibt es aber sowohl mit Flickercode, als auch mit QR-Code.
Was ist denn ein Flickercode?
Flickercode ist das, was die Sparkung gemacht hat. Im Wesentlichen sieht es ähnlich aus wie ein Barcode, also fünf weiße Flecken auf dem Bildschirm, die nacheinander aufblitzen. Dann kommt dann halt die Daten nacheinander rein. Okay. Das andere Verfahren dazu sind 2D, 3D, farbige Bar-QR-Codes, so ähnlich wie QR-Codes, was mit Farben drin ist. Fototan heißt das dann. Die Daten übertragen werden sind die gleichen. Dann gibt es andere, da musst du dann in der App bestätigen. Einige, die nicht in der App bestätigen, sondern in der App die TAN anzeigen. Und hatten wir noch was?
Aber trotzdem, das kommt mir momentan noch wie so ein Problem vor, dass halt Menschen haben, die neuen Konten haben. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das problematisch ist, aber das ist ja auch eher die Ausnahme, oder?
Oder Menschen, die zum Beispiel eine Firma haben.
Die eine Firma haben, weil du dann auch mehrere Konten in der Regel hast.
Nein, weil es ist absolut nicht mehr möglich, Daten automatisch zu verarbeiten.
Was?
Früher, 2018 war...
Wenn du dir den Skript gegen dein Konto werfen möchtest, musst du uns auch irgendwann mal diese TAN eingeben.
2018 war ja nicht alles schlecht. Wir hatten ja Konto zu Griff. Es gab ja ein Protokoll.
Warte mal, müssen wir jetzt von vorne anfangen quasi?
Nein.
Dass wir mal über Online-Banking reden?
Ich weiß nicht so richtig. Also du hattest das ja offenbar noch nicht.
Na ja.
Also als Firma hab ich halt meine lokale Buchhaltung. In der gibt es ein Modul, da sag ich dann irgendwie so Kontonummer und PIN. Und dann ruft die von dort die Kontobewegungen ab. Das geht halt jetzt nicht mehr, weil das manchmal eine TAN braucht. Und wenn der Prozess auf irgendeinem Server im Hintergrund läuft bei mir in der Firma, dann geht das nicht mehr. Also nicht mehr zuverlässig. Und dann hat sich halt der Hersteller der Software gedacht, anstatt dass es nicht mehr zuverlässig geht, schalten wir es ganz ab.
Ja.
Also du hattest halt bisher die Möglichkeit auch zu Hause mit deinem Onlinebanking über Fintes, was früher HBCI war, auf der Kontobe zu zukaufen.
War was, was, was?
Naja, also es gibt Schnittstellen fürs Onlinebanking. Das kannst du deine Software kaufen, StarMoney oder hier Alkubanking oder Linux oder was auch immer. Und die können auf deine Konto zugreifen mit Passwort und Kontonummer.
Ich würde gerade sogar das Subjekt-Objekt tauschen. Das geht jetzt nicht mehr.
Also es geht schon, aber halt deutlich komplizierter und manchmal will es nicht handen. Und was ich halt hatte, ich hatte im Hintergrund...
Stopp, stopp, halt, halt Leute, halt. Ich fang jetzt mal ganz von vorne an, ja. Also das Internet.
Genau.
Irgendwann gab es Webseiten und dann gab es...
Unendliche Weiten.
Unendliche Weiten und irgendwann, also dann gab es Porno. Und dann gab es irgendwann auch die Banken, die gesagt haben, hey, vielleicht könnte man ja dieses ganze Überweisungsding ohne das Papier machen, sondern einfach über eine Webseite. So, dann gab es dieses Ding, man lockt sich in die Webseite ein und gibt ein Passwort dazu ein.
Genau, du hast einen Teil vergessen, dass wir Deutschland sind. Wir machen alles anders. Die Deutschen hatten BTX.
Okay, das ist jetzt sehr weit zurück.
Und das Datenträger-Austausch-Verfahren.
Das BTX war das, was man in Online-Banking in Deutschland vorher gemacht hat. Also da gab es auch nicht mal diese Online-Banking-Webseiten, sondern du hast halt hierzulande schon früher Online-Banking machen können, auf komischen BTX-Seiten. Gleiches Verfahren, benutzt einmal Passwort, Kontonummer, PIN.
Okay, aber wenn man nicht so alt ist, dass man BTX noch praktisch kannte?
Der Trick an der Stelle ist, dass das dann irgendwann standardisiert wurde. Dass du es nicht mehr auf einer Webseite machen musst, sondern dass eine Software das in deinem Auftrag tun kann. Dass du zum Beispiel alle Überweisungen, weil Online-Zeit kostet, wir sind immer noch in der Zeit, wo man sich einwählt und dann fiept das Modem ganz furchtbar und dann fängt der Minutenzähler an zu zählen. Das heißt, du bereitest deinen Überweisungsstapel vorher fertig vor, dann wählt sich deine Software ein, sendet den Überweisungsstapel, führt die Transaktion aus und trennt die Verbindung wieder. Ist halt besser, als wenn du ein Webseitenformular lest und während du das ausfüllst, tickt der Minuten, also Dings.
So, dann, aber das hat man als Privatmensch sozusagen nicht gemacht, sondern sich einfach eingeloggt mit wie auch immer Nutzername, Kontonummer und dann halt ein paar Fotos in den Film.
Deswegen wollte ich sagen, als Privatmensch hast du das gemacht, weil du mit deiner T-Online-Software in den 90ern die Software dazugekriegt hast.
Was es dann auch noch gab, dass du deine Transaktionen auf einer Diskette gespeichert hast und die zur Bank getragen hast.
Genau, das ist dann nicht so ganz Online-Banking, sondern das ist einfach nur der Teil mit der Digitalisierung und dem nicht mehr abtippen müssen.
Was dabei ganz wichtig ist, weil aus diesem Disketten-Ding, das sich Datenträger-Austauschverfahren nennt, daraus haben sie irgendwann HBC gebastelt.
Moment, stopp! Also Webseite mit einem Login. Die Sicherheit besteht darin, dass ich im Idealfall der Einzige, mit dem er das Passwort kennt, wenn ich mich eingeloggt habe, weiß die Gegenüberseite, okay, das ist er anscheinend. Wie stellt denn die Bank sicher, dass auf der Diskette, die jetzt im Schlitz da im Bankbriefkasten eingeworfen wurde, derjenige, der die Daten abgespeichert hat, der auf das Konto zugreifen darf?
Mit deiner Unterschrift.
Mit meiner was?
Da gab es einen Begleitzettel, da ist dann im Wesentlichen die Prüf-Summe aller Überweisungen abgedruckt. Und du setzt deinen Frank-Willi drunter und bestätigst, dass diese Daten korrekt sind.
Okay, naja, immerhin fast genauso sicher wie eine handgeschriebene Überweisung. Prüf-Summe, ganz kurz, man rechnet über Daten etwas aus, dass eine Zahl gibt, die schwer fälschbar ist.
Genau, es ist sehr schwierig, die Daten so zu verändern, dass die Summe gleich bleibt.
Okay, genau. Okay, dann so. Und dann ist man aber irgendwann so relativ schnell auf den Trichter gekommen, naja, dass mit irgendwie nur Nutzer- namen und Passwort ist so ein bisschen wenig. Das könnte sich ja jemand abgucken.
Das war, glaube ich, schon ganz am Anfang. Wir sind ja die Deutschen, die überall immer ganz, also Tannenlisten gab es schon sehr früh.
Sehr schnell, sozusagen.
Bei HBCI war das erste Sicherheitsmedium tatsächlich aber nicht Tannenlisten, sondern Chipkarte. Mit deiner tatsächlich im Volksmund EC-Karte, also der Girocard, deiner Sparkassen-Kundenkarte oder welche Bank auch immer. Da war schon seit wirklich langer Zeit auch eine Funktion drauf, die sonst keiner verwendet hat. Die konntest du in ein Chipkartengerät reinstecken und damit die Banktransaktion freigeben.
Das heißt, die Sicherheit bestand darin, dass ich zwei Dinge habe, die sich halt generieren. Das eine ist das Passwort, was idealerweise nur ich kenne. Das andere ist die Karte, die idealerweise nur ich habe.
Genau.
Oder...
Bei Besitz sperren. Bei Verlust sperren.
Ich möchte die Karte wegen Besitz sperren. Wait, what? Oder halt die Tannenliste, wo dasselbe gilt, die habe im Idealfall nur ich. So, dann war der nächste Schritt, glaube ich, Tann per SMS.
Genau, dann gab es halt größere Mengen von Fishing unter anderem. Das heißt, Leute haben E-Mails gekriegt, in denen stand, sie müssen folgende Dinge, was auch immer tun, Änderung des Sicherheitsverfahrens, total guter Grund, den man vorgeben kann. Klicken Sie hier auf diese Webseite, geben Sie hier Ihre online Lock-in-Daten ein und bestätigen Sie die Änderung des Sicherheitsverfahrens mit einer Tann. Oder mit dreien.
Ja, bestens, ja klar.
Und es gab dann ausreichend viele Leute, die darauf reingefallen sind, sodass dann weniger nette Leute Tanns abgegriffen haben. Die erste Nummer war dann, dass die Tannen, das nicht betreibeliebige Tanz, so war das nämlich früher, sondern dass man bestimmte Tanns eingeben musste. Für diese Überweisung geben Sie jetzt bitte Tannen 37 an. Und nicht jede andere. Dazu muss man zuerst die Überweisung abgeben. Und dann wurde festgelegt, zu dieser Überweisung gehört folgende Tann. Das sollte dann gegen Bösewichte schützen. Die Bösewichte sind natürlich auch nicht doof und haben den offensichtlichen Fall. Die machen quasi das Inline. Während du das Formular ausfüllst, in dem du deine Sicherheitsdings machst, geben die hinten um die Überweisung ein. Holen sich die Nummer der Tann, die sie brauchen, und leiten das quasi direkt durch.
Ich glaube, ich hab natürlich mal ein Chaosradio. So lange mach ich das schon moderiert, wo wir genau über diesen Angriff gesprochen haben. Das muss schon eine Weile her sein.
Und da gab es halt andere Leute, die dachten, hey, das ist ganz cool, das verkaufen wir als Geschäftskonzept. Daraus ist dann diese Sofortüberweisung entstanden. Exakt identische Vorgehensweise. Ach wirklich? Du gibst deine Daten bei Sofortüberweisung ein. Sofortüberweisung gibt sie auf der Bank-Webseite ein. Bank-Webseite sagt, folgende verfügbare Betrag. Sofortüberweisung gibt eine Überweisung bei deiner Bank an. Bank sagt, bitte geben sie Tann sonst da was ein. Das sagt Sofortüberweisung dir.
Wow.
Das nennt man Mende, Mittelangriff?
Das Schöne ist ja, Sofortüberweisung hat damit geworden, dass das halt ja sofort bestätigt wird an den Web-Shop oder wo auch immer der es eingebunden hat. Und was Sofortüberweisung auch getan hat, im Hintergrund deine letzten Transaktionen von deinem Konto runtergeladen, um damit quasi deine Bonität zu prüfen. Weil da haben sie ja gesehen, ob du Regelmäßigkeit bekommst oder so.
Das heißt, meinen Impuls zu sagen, nee, das ist bäh, weil eigentlich ist das...
Ist doch total toll. Sie haben hoch und heilig versprochen, deine Daten nicht zu missbrauchen. Und sich, glaube ich, sogar ein TÜV-Siegel geholt. Und noch irgendwie so eine Versicherung von irgendeinem Unternehmen, die, falls doch mal was schiefgeht oder so. Das finde ich immer sehr vertrauenswürdig, wenn eine Webseite sagt, wir sind so toll, wir sind sogar versichert.
Das Witzige ist, die Banken haben dann versucht, dagegen zu klagen. Und gesagt, hier Sofortüberweisung, die loggen sich da im Namen des Kunden ein. Das ist AGB-Verstoß und so. Und das Gerichtsurteil sagte aber nein. Sofortüberweisung kannst du nicht verklagen, weil eure Kunden verstoßen ja gegen die AGB und nicht Sofortüberweisung. Im Gegenteil, wenn ihr das Webscraping verhindert, dann seid ihr wettbewerbsverstoßmäßig dran, weil ihr das Geschäftsmodell von Sofortüberweisung kaputtmacht.
Insbesondere, wenn die Banken versuchen, ein anderes System nach außen eine ähnliche Funktionalität anzubieten. Bei den Sparkassen war das so, da hörte ich die Geschichte, dass die mal versucht haben, das zu blocken, dann hat Sofortüberweisung die IP-Adressen geändert, von denen sie kamen. Bei anderen Banken hörte ich, dass Sofortüberweisung ein größeres Problem hatte, weil diese Bank ein Developer-Demo-Login hatte. Wenn du dich mit folgenden Kontodaten einlogst, dann kommst du auf ein virtuelles Konto, das ist immer gedeckt und akzeptiert alle Überweisungen. Was dann halt Leute rausgefunden haben und bei einem Webshop per Sofortüberweisung Waren bestellt. Dann hat sich halt Sofortüberweisung hochrot, was auch immer, beschwert bei dieser Bank und gemeldet hier, was ist denn da mit diesem Developer-Account und so weiter und so. Was haben wir hier gewollt?
Was ich ganz interessant finde, historisch gesehen sind wir also an einem Zeitpunkt, es gibt das Internet oder es gibt das Web, es gibt Online-Shops und es gibt das Problem, also das ist noch weit vor dem flächendeckenden Einsatz von Kreditkarten. Also da hatte noch nicht jeder einen.
In Deutschland.
Genau, in Deutschland. Jetzt erst mal von Deutschland gesehen. Es gab noch nicht so was wie PayPal.
Doch, also diese PayPal ist älter als Sofortüberweisung, wenn ich mich nicht alles täusche. Sofortüberweisung ist richtig alt, ist irgendwie 2006. Also 2006, PayPal weiß ich gerade nicht. Also ja, die Situation ist tatsächlich, die Amerikaner machen Online-Bestellungen mit Kreditkarte. Die Deutschen haben schon immer Online-Banking. Aber keine Kreditkarten.
Also was ich sagen wollte, wir hatten schon eine Zeit lang hier in Deutschland, wo das quasi so war, dass diese Möglichkeiten, PayPal oder Kreditkarte nicht so verbreitet waren. Und man in diese absurden Situationen steckte. Also im Prinzip könnte ich bestellen und der Online-Shop könnte es sofort rausschicken. Macht er aber nicht, solange er kein Geld hat. Dann gab es sowas wie Nachname.
Vorkasse und Nachname waren die anderen Optionen.
Genau, Vorkasse ist halt, man überweist, dann hat man als Kunde aber keine Ahnung, ob der Webshop jetzt vertrauenswürdig ist. Nachname ist immer sehr teuer. Das war dann immer so ein Zehner noch mal obendrauf, grob. Und also die Idee, wir leben jetzt in einer Online-Welt und die Frage, wie kann ich dem Webshop, also das ist quasi eine vertrauenswürdige dritte Stelle gesagt, die dem Webshop einfach zu verstehen geht, ja, da hat jetzt jemand das Geld überwiesen. Der kann auch sofort Überweisung nicht die Einzigen gewesen sein, die die Idee hatten. Und gab es da andere Ansätze?
Genau, zum Beispiel die Sparkassen haben das richtig rumgemacht. Bei denen hieß das GiroPay. Das heißt, du gibst bei dem Händler nur noch deine Bankleitzahl ein, glaube ich. Der übermittelt dann an die Sparkasse, hier dieser Kunde soll bitte mal so und so viel Euro an mich bezahlen. Die Sparkasse lässt dich bei sich im normalen Online-Banking einloggen, nicht bei irgendeinem anderen. Der Überweisungsträger ist quasi ein vorausgefüllter Überweisungsträger online. Du machst eine ganz normale Online-Überweisung. Bloß, dass die Sparkasse weiß, dass sie zu einem Händler gehört und direkt die Rückmeldung gibt, diese Überweisung wurde ausgeführt.
Und da war dann wahrscheinlich das Problem, dass es dann sozusagen eine Bank gewesen ist, anbietet und die ganz anderen...
Genau, Sparkassenverband und noch ein paar andere haben mitgemacht. Das war nicht so ganz großes Netzwerk. Plus niemand wollte es haben, weil es auf Händlerseite wohl teuer war.
Okay, also wir haben es hier wie immer in Deutschland auch mit einem selbstgemachten Problem zu tun, wo man die Digitalisierung einfach verschläft.
Genau. Wir haben ja auch unseren eigenen PayPal-Klon, der nichts geworden ist und so weiter.
Von den Sambal-Brüdern oder?
Nee, nee, ich meine tatsächlich vom Bankenverband. Es gibt es etwas, das eine PayPal-ähnliche Funktionalität hat.
Wow, das ist so grandios gescheitert, dass ich es nicht einmal mitbekomme.
Sie sehen, wie bekannt es ist.
Genau, letztes Jahr erst wieder weiter geworden ist.
Das Interessante ist ja aber, dass das schon relativ lange her ist. Wenn ich es richtig verstehe, ist, um bei den politischen Sachen zu bleiben, ist das etwas, was PSD2 versucht hat zu klären?
P-Direct. Also, schon vorher, es gab ja die PSD ohne zwei. Da geht es aber vor allem um die Regulierung von Zahlungsdienstleistern. Also von Banken im Wesentlichen.
Ja, aber unser Status war ja gerade, wir waren bei der Sache mit den Tann-Listen.
Genau.
Oder der Chipkarte, die man in ein Gerät reinsteckt. Und dann Tann per SMS, weil böse Leute Tanns abgefragt haben.
Oder andere Tann-Mechanismen, die gab es auch schon immer.
Also die mit einer Hand, oder?
Flickertann ist halt, wenn man nicht das Unsichere mit der SMS möchte, das haben wir ja schon ein paar Mal gehört.
SMS ist sozusagen schon das Unsicherste von allen dynamisch generierten Tanns. Weil?
Weil die SMS quasi im Klartext durch die Luft übertragen wird. Es ist, also je nach Angreifermodell finde ich SMS Tann unsicherer als Eitann.
Eitann ist nochmal?
Ja, es gab bei SMS auch sehr witzige Dinge. Also vielleicht, wenn ich eine kurze Anekdote einfliegen darf. Es gab mal also durchaus Banken, die SMS sehr teuer fanden zu versenden. Also haben sie den billigsten Angebäter gesucht. Und einer dieser SMS-Versender hat so funktioniert, dass du als normaler Mensch dein Freikontingent an SMS, was du am Monatsende noch übrig hattest oder so was, mit einer App verwenden konntest. Das heißt, du hast dich angemeldet auf einer Website und hast Geld dafür bekommen, SMS zu versenden. Und damit wurden dann Tanz und andere Sachen über Privathandys von Leuten versendet, die sich dafür registriert hatten.
Wow! Genau, oder es gibt halt mehr als eine Möglichkeit, einfach die Nummer auf sich umzuleiten, wenn man mal freundlich bei der Telekom oder welchem Anbieter auch immer fragt. Hallo, ich bin, ich hab neue, meine Simkarte verloren, geben Sie mir mal eine neue auf diese Nummer. Oder es gibt, also wir haben diese Angriffe auf dem Kongress häufiger mal gehabt, sowohl auf das Übertragungsnetz als auch auf den Funkkanal.
Also das ist wirklich ein Geheimagenten-Film-Style. Du stehst irgendwo mit einer Antenne und fängst SMS aus der Luft ab.
Genau, kannst du sagen, in die Luft halten, den nassen Finger und kommt die SMS mehr oder weniger. Das war lange Zeit möglich. Das ist, oh tu, glaube ich, vorletztes Jahr auf die Füße gefallen. Als das das erste Mal in Deutschland gruselig passierte. Die Hacker haben es immer schon vorher gesagt. Natürlich. Im Gegenzug, die Tannliste ist ja ein physisches Stück Papier, was bei dir zu Hause mindestens in der Schreibtischschublade liegt. Vielleicht sogar in der verschlossenen Schreibtischschublade. Wenn jemand haben möchte, muss er bei dir einbrechen. Hast du Einbruchsspuren, Versicherungen, Polizeibericht? Find ich ein anderes Bedrohungsszenario.
Aber gab es jemals die Möglichkeit, sicher vor Fishing zu sein?
Wirklich? Genau, stimmt. Du darfst natürlich dann im Gegenzug deine Daten nicht bei Fishingseiten eingeben. Ja.
Aber bei SMS doch eigentlich genauso. Weil der Fishinganspruch, den Angriff, den du beschrieben hast, dem ich schalte mich quasi als man in the middle zwischen die Bank-Webseite, rufe die auf und relaye die Informationen, müsste doch auch mit SMS funktionieren.
Na das vertraut darauf, dass du nicht doof bist, was wir bei Fishing... In der SMS steht nämlich nochmal die Überweisungsdaten drin. Da steht dann, so und so viele Euro werden an dem Punkt überwiesen. Natürlich steht auf der Betrüger-Webseite drin, ignorieren sie den Text, das ist jetzt bloß eine Testnachricht.
Der andere Angriff ist der Trojaner, der auf deinem Rechner drauf ist. Und in deinem Online-Banking eine Überweisung einfügt in die Webseite, die gar nicht da ist. Und dann siehst du, das ist eine Fehluberweisung. Ich hab da 1000 Euro überwiesen bekommen, du bist ja ehrlich. Und dann klickst du auf diesen kleinen Button daneben, wo Zurücküberweisen steht. Und dann überweist du dem Angreifer das Geld mit normalem Banking. Wie schlecht.
Befasse, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Es wird dir vorgegaukelt, dass auf deinem Konto ein Zahlungseingang wäre. Und du als ehrlicher Finder möchtest das Geld gerne zurückgeben.
Ah, und das ist dann aber einfach nur eine normale Überweisung.
Genau. Also zumindest eine von den beiden Überweisungen ist echt.
Verstehe, verstehe. Aber da muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen, wenn man einen Trojan aufrechnet, hat man eh verloren.
Genau, der fordert dich dann auch zum Sicherheitsupdate auf dem Telefon auf.
Okay, dann ist eh alles gelaufen. Es gibt immer das eine Szenario, wo es egal ist, wie viel Sicherheitsabsturz es gibt.
Nein, also deswegen, ChipTan hat halt den Vorteil eines externen Geräts. Das sieht aus wie ein kleiner Taschenrechner oder nicht ganz, also wie ein TAN-Generator halt. Da ist ein Display drin und das ist ziemlich sicher, dass dieses Display das anzeigt, was wahr ist.
Aber da kriege ich ja auch wieder nur eine Nummer gesagt, die ich irgendwo eintippen muss.
Ja, aber vorher steht die Kontonummer drauf. Und der Betrag.
Naja, aber bei dem Beispiel von euch sozusagen steht natürlich die Kontonummer. Deswegen mein ich, dass es beim Trojaner ist halt schwierig.
Ja, das stimmt. Wenn dir vorgegaukelt wird, ja, Rücküberweisung machst du einfach nicht.
Fertig.
Aber es hilft halt gegen dieses Standardding, dass du auf eine Fischene-Webseite gehst. Oder dass du...
Okay, ja, das verstehe ich.
Deswegen will man das zweite Gerät haben, was nicht dein Rechner ist. Und bisher war auch das der Ansatz, warum du kein Online-Baking auf deinem Handy machen können solltest, wenn dein Handy auch das Sicherheitsmerkmal war.
Das ist schon ein Schritt zu weit. Da wollen wir erst noch hin. Wir sind momentan erst mal auf einem Rechner. Man kriegt die TAN. Die kommt jetzt nicht mehr per SMS, nicht mehr per Kartenlesegerät, sondern es gibt jetzt... Das hast du ITANs genannt? Das ist, glaube ich, einfach der Überbegriff für...
Nee, ITAN, das ist die TAN-Liste mit der Nummer vorne dran.
Ah, okay, dann war das...
ChipTAN ist das generische von der EC-Karte.
Ja, und wie heißt das aus der App?
PushTAN manchmal oder AppTAN, je nachdem.
So, dann habe ich also eine App, die diese TAN generiert. Jetzt frage ich, da fragt man sich ja als allererstes...
Weil er eigentlich nur anzeigt. Nicht generiert. Generiert wird sie ja von der Band.
Kommt drauf an.
Das wäre nämlich meine nächste Frage gewesen.
Genau, deswegen hat es verschiedene Bezeichnungen. FototAN, AppTAN oder PushTAN. FototAN ist ein Verfahren, das so ähnlich funktioniert wie mit der Chipcard. Also es gibt ein Geheimnis, was in deinem Telefon gespeichert ist. Die Banküberweisungsdaten kommen per QR-Code. Und das verknüpft dann das Geheimnis irgendwie mit den Banküberweisungsdaten und generiert daraus die DITAN. Beziehungsweise, ich glaube, lassen wir es dabei. Die andere Variante ist, dass die App ein Geheimnis hat, dass es ihr erlaubt, sicher mit der Bank zu kommunizieren. Und kriegt per normaler Datenübertragung per Internet die DITAN-Übermittel, die sie anzeigen soll.
Na ja, oder ganz krude, du musst mit deinem Fingerabdruck einfach nur bestätigen, dass diese Transaktion freizugeben ist. Und alles andere passiert magisch im Hintergrund.
Aber mit deinem Fingerabdruck bestätigen heißt in dem Fall, die...
DITAN wird einfach nicht angezeigt, sondern gleich hintenrum wieder zurückgeweist.
Aber Fingerabdruck heißt sozusagen, da verlässt man sich darauf, dass die biometrische Erkennung in dem Telefon funktioniert. Nicht die App selber kann einen Fingerabdruck lesen.
Genau, das verlässt sich dann auch die Sicherheitsmerkmale deines Telefons. Moderne Telefone haben einen sicheren Bereich, der irgendwie lokal geschützt ist und auch gegen Angreifer halbwegs gesichert ist. Und es ermöglichen müsste, wenn du dich gegenüber dem Telefon korrekt ausweist, durch Gesicht, Fingerabdruck oder Pin, dass das Telefon irgendwelche Dinge tut, die niemand sonst tun kann.
Okay, und die TANs werden nicht auf dem Gerät generiert, sondern das Gerät kennt nur das Geheimnis. Das ist dann quasi nicht die Chipkarte, das ist nicht das Papierliste, sondern es ist sozusagen eine Zahlenfolge, die in dem Gerät drin ist. Da hat man jetzt aber tatsächlich doch noch einen weiteren Angriffspunkt, dass man einfach diese App angreifen kann, oder?
Ja, also dafür hast du ja ein, naja, kommt auf das Betriebsystem an und welche Sicherheitslücken bekannt sind in dem Betriebssystem.
Gut, da müsste man immer gucken, in welchem Tag sind wir gerade, aber es hat ja jedes Betriebssystem schon mal fair erwischt.
Aber das ist einer der Gründe, warum die ja bei den guten Telefonen sich weigern, online Banken zu machen. Weil es halt keine Garantie mehr gibt, dass nicht ein Rootprozess auf all diese Daten zugreift.
Das sind schon wieder zwei Schritte, sozusagen sehr weit vorne.
Aber genau, eigentlich ist das die Kernfunktion deines Telephones, dass die Apps voneinander getrennt sind und keine App eine andere beeinflussen oder angreifen können sollte. Das ist zumindest das Versprechen, dass jedes dieser Telefonbetriebssysteme schon im Amt in verschiedenen Ausprägungen.
Und das ist auch realistisch?
Apple gibt sich da relativ gut Mühe an ganz vielen Stellen. Google gibt sich Mühe.
Also das heißt, das kann man schon ernst nehmen als Ansatz? So, jetzt kurz zu dem Routing. Das heißt also, das Mobiltelefon oder beziehungsweise die Banken sagen also dann anscheinend, solange das Mobiltelefon in dem Zustand ist, den der Hersteller vorgesehen hat, würden wir uns darauf verlassen, dass diese Tannen-Übertragungs-App funktioniert. So, und jetzt das mit dem Routen. Das ist das dann nicht mehr.
Genau, also in dem Moment, in dem ich mein Telefon geroutet habe, kann ich als Anwender ja zum einen weitere Plikationen installieren. Und ich habe übrigerweise halt irgendwo ein Programm, das ich aufrufe, um Routes zu werden. Du musst kurz sagen, Routes werden ist? Routes werden heißt, ich bin, so wie auf meinem Rechner zu Hause Super-User, ich darf alles und alle diese Beschränkungen gelten für mich nicht mehr.
Also normalerweise ist der Speicher, in dem das Geheimnis drin ist, zum Beispiel nicht auslesbar.
Und ab dem Moment kann es natürlich passieren, dass eine Route-Applikation oder dass ein Chartcode eben auch sich diese Rechte holt und damit dann das Online-Banking manipulieren kann.
Also die Online-Banking-Apps können erkennen, ob ich mir als Besitzer Zugriff auf das Telefon verschafft habe, den der Hersteller nicht vorgesehen hat und sagt dann, wenn du das kannst, könnte das theoretisch auch jemand Böses und deswegen funktionieren wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Genau, sie versuchen es, hat Muttex gerade schon richtig gesagt. Technisch gesehen muss man ja sagen, der Zustand des geroutet Seins ist ein Zustand, in dem das Telefon in der Lage ist, dich über seinen Zustand anzulügen. Ein nicht geroutetes Zustand kann dich nicht über seinen Zustand anlügen, sondern sagt dir immer, was wahr ist. Und ein Telefon, auf dem du als Endnutzer und nicht der Hersteller die Kontrolle hat, kann prinzipiell über seinen Zustand lügen. Was es dir also sagt, wenn es dir sagt, ich funktioniere auf diesem Telefon, ist, das Gerät ist in einem Zustand, in dem es mich über seinen Zustand anliegen könnte und deswegen will ich nicht funktionieren.
Okay, verstehe.
Ich erkenne, dass das Gerät in einem Zustand ist, in dem es nicht...
Aber dann gibt es doch sicherlich Leute, die versucht haben, dem Telefon zu sagen, hier ist doch alles völlig in Ordnung.
Das hab ich dann auch gehabt. Ich hatte das Problem auch. Es gibt bei Android mittlerweile relativ gute Toolkits. Magisk ist so ungefähr das Letzte. Die sehr gut sich verstecken vor Applikationen. Die versuchen das zu detektieren. Also das Telefon lernt besser Lügen.
Ist das dann ein Wettlauf, der mal so mal so ausgeht?
Ja, und dann kommt Google wieder und macht irgendwas anderes. Dann finden die Entwickler wieder einen Gegenweg.
So.
Eine Rüstungsspirale.
Das ist also die technische Voraussetzung für die ganze Geschichte. Ich hab das jetzt auch so ausführlich gefragt, weil ich mich schon gefragt habe, diese Nummer mit, ihr habt gesagt, wenn man als Firma, also ihr habt gesagt, wenn man seine Dinge per Programm verarbeiten will, dann ist diese ganze TAN-Nummer eher unpraktisch. Wenn ich jetzt so genau überlege, stelle ich fest, wenn ich ein Programm schreiben würde, das für mich online Banking macht, dann könnte ich ja so eine TAN-Liste zum Beispiel auch in so ein Programm einfüttern.
Genau, das war früher auch der übliche Weg. Wurde immer abgeraten, darf man nicht machen, AGB-Verstoß und so weiter. Aber alle Online-Banking-Programme...
Es gibt Leute, die das gemacht haben...
.alle Online-Banking-Programme hatten schon immer die Möglichkeit, dass man die TAN-Liste einfach komplett einmal eingebt.
Insbesondere für das Abrufen der Konteninformation und der Umsätze brauchtest du ja keine TAN.
Es war immer die starke Unterscheidung zwischen nur Lesen und Lese-Schreibzugriff.
So, dann wie ist das mit SMS-TAN? Da könnte man auch denken, also gut, dann schließe ich halt ein Handy an den Computer an, dann macht er das auch automatisch.
Nee, als offizielles Projekt, glaube ich. Also ja, prinzipiell kann man auch mit dem Chipkarten-Dings einfach einen Chipkartenleser anschließen. Das ist, glaube ich, so mein übernächstes Projekt, um das zu begehen.
Ich hatte eine HBC-Karte, die konnte ich halt ins Lesegerät reintun. Und akkubenken konnte ich die PIN dafür festgeben.
Genau, HBC ist aber das andere, das war ohne TAN. Sondern das war das, wo die Chipkarte selber, das war direkt dafür vorgesehen, dass es automatisiert funktioniert.
Aha, es gab da Ansätze. Jemand hat drüber nachgedacht, wie geht das auch ohne TAN, aber trotzdem mit einem zusätzlichen Sicherheitsfaktor?
Genau, das war das vorherige, das ältere. TAN ist Version 3 der Spezifikation.
Warte, das heißt, ich habe etwas missverstanden. Das heißt, es gibt zwei Geräte, wo man so eine Karte reinstecken kann. Das eine, wo das Reinstecken der Karte schon das Sicherheitsmerkmal ist, und das andere, wo das Reinstecken der Karte das Generieren einer TAN auslöst.
Ja. Also in der vorherigen Version, bis 2002 glaube ich, von HBCI bzw. FINTS, war das einzige Sicherheitsmerkmal die Chipkarte. Die hat dann das gleiche gemacht, wie was wir eben besprochen haben, viele Jahre später das Telefon, einen sicheren Kanal zwischen der Karte und der Bank. Das heißt, alles, was die Karte unterschrieben hat als Gürtelzoo, hat die Bank akzeptiert. Und man musste sich der Karte gegenüber nur noch mit PIN ausweisen.
Also quasi wie im Geschäft bezahlen, mit dem Unterschied, dass ich online wegging.
Genau. Sieht für den Benutzer so ähnlich aus.
Okay. Und das heißt aber?
Das hat sich weitestgehend nicht durchgesetzt, weil es keine Web-Technologie war. Es ist kein HTTP im Spiel gewesen. Schon mal ganz schlechte Voraussetzung. Nicht im Webbrowser funktioniert, sondern man muss halt eine Software runterladen und installieren. Und man muss einen Chipkartenleser haben, die auch heute nicht so verbreitet sind.
Aber das, gerade wenn du sagst, ich habe eine Firma und so.
Genau, bei Firmen das Standardverfahren, ja. So. Und dann kam halt Version 3 mit der TAN.
Mit der TAN in der App und gibt es da Dinge, wie man sozusagen seinen Online-Backing automatisieren kann und trotzdem App-TANs irgendwie den Weg da reinfinden?
Es ist zumindest nicht vorgesehen und technisch gesehen, also eigentlich ist es verboten. Das ist nämlich jetzt die zweite.
Das ist die eine Sache. Die andere Sache ist, ist es praktikabel?
Je nach Banken, die Banken wieten unterschiedliche Verfahren an. Zum Beispiel ChipTAN, das war das mit dem Flickercode oder so, könnte ich mir vorstellen, zu automatisieren. SMS auch, wenn man halt eine SMS-Nummer angibt. SMS gibt es ja nicht mehr, so rum. Man könnte ein geroutetes Telefon nehmen. Und direkt anschließen.
Das mit dem Rechner dann kommunizieren.
Also Flickercode lässt sich automatisieren. Ich kenne Menschen, die haben einen Python-Skript geschrieben, um aus dem GIF, was von der Bank geschickt wird, die Daten zu extrahieren und eine Chipkarte, die lokal eingesteckt ist, zu schicken und das zurückzumachen.
Okay, so, jetzt habe ich noch eine wichtige Nachfrage, weil ich glaube, die wird dann später wichtig, nämlich über alles, was wir hier gesprochen haben, das findet momentan zwischen zwei Parteien statt.
Genau.
Ich vor meinem Rechner und sozusagen am anderen Ende der Internetleitung die Bank.
Genau, der Bankrechner und mein Rechner.
Genau, also auch diese ganze App-Generierung und sowas läuft alles, es ist alles Kommunikationsverkehr mit meinem Online.
Also bei der App ist klar, da kommt irgendwo noch Google mit rein oder was weiß ich, aber hat zumindest mit den Zahlungsdaten nichts zu tun.
Okay, wir müssen irgendwann wieder zurück zu PSD2, aber ich habe noch eine letzte Frage. Weil das Mutters vorhin auch schon gesagt hat, da würde ich da jetzt wieder hin. Nämlich dieses, wenn die App auf dem Handy Meditang generiert, dann hat er gesagt, ja, aber eine Zeit lang war es so, man sollte dann nicht das Online-Banking auf demselben Gerät machen. Das ist so, also ich habe mich, Anekdotenzeit, ich habe versucht, ein Bahnticket zu kaufen, in der App, mit meiner Kreditkarte, glaube ich. Dann ist folgendes passiert. Die Bahn-App hat einen extra Step in der Kreditkarten-Abbuchung gemacht. Ich glaube, das hat auch was damit zu tun. Das wiederum eine extra Pin erfordert hat, die generiert wird, wenn ich mich bei meiner Bank einlocke, was ich gemacht habe. Und dann aber eine TAN generieren musste, die in einer extra App generiert wurde. Und dann habe ich das gemacht, bin zurück in die Banking-App, habe da die TAN eingegeben. Dann hat es mir die Kreditkarten-TAN, dann bin ich zurück in das Fenster, habe die Kreditkarten-TAN eingegeben. Und dann ist die Bahn-App schon wieder zugegangen gewesen, weil es zu lange gedauert hat. Ich musste alles von vorne anfangen. Frage, aber in dem Moment habe ich mich auch gefragt, das ist doch eigentlich totaler Quatsch, wenn ich diese ganzen Geheimnisse auf einem Gerät mache. Das hatte ich so als Impuls. Ist das so oder ist das eigentlich, weil ihr habt ja auch erzählt, im Prinzip, wenn das Gerät nicht aufgemacht ist, kann man davon ausgehen, das funktioniert schon irgendwie mit der Sicherheitsstellung, ist das eigentlich sozusagen kein Gedanke, den man sich heutzutage machen muss.
Genau, das ist einfach nur überkompliziert, deimplementiert gewesen an der Stelle, aber hätte so funktionieren können sollen.
Also das ist auch sicher sozusagen. Es ist kein Quatsch, dass die Bank sagt, auf demselben Kredit.
Es wäre ohne das auch sicher gewesen.
Das Problem ist halt, dass die Kreditkarten gar nicht mehr von den Banken selber ausgegeben und gemacht werden. Also bis jetzt wurden sie noch nie. Die Kreditkarte kommt ja irgendwie von Mastercard, Visa oder sonst jemandem. Die wollen da jetzt auch Sicherheit einbauen und machen deswegen die Verifikation mit der Bank hin und her, wenn du einen Online-Einkauf machst.
Nee, das ist schon klar. Ich wollte jetzt wirklich nur wissen, dieses Ding, dass sowohl die Transaktion als auch das Geheimnis, dass diese Transaktion sicher machen soll, auf demselben Gerät stattfinden, ist kein Grund zur Sorge.
Nein, an sich nicht.
Okay. Gut, haben wir jetzt die technischen Hintergründe fertig?
Bestimmt nicht, aber wird sich noch finden.
Wollen wir dann jetzt eine kleine Pause machen?
Oh ja, haben wir Musik dafür.
Und dann haben wir Musik für. Wir haben da etwas vorbereitet. Und zwar von Lemon Wizard hören wir jetzt New Beginnings. Passt doch schön zum Thema New Beginnings fürs Online-Banking. Und dann machen wir weiter mit PSD2 Chaosradio 256. Chaosradio 256, wir reden über PSD2, die Pay Service Directive 2 und haben jetzt in den ersten Teil der Sendung damit zugebracht, rauszufinden, wie wir technologisch an den Stand gekommen sind, dass wir, wenn wir online Überweisungen machen, Apps auf unseren Smartphones haben, die uns dort meist sechsstellige Zahlen generieren, die wir eingeben müssen. So und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, regelt ja diese PSD2 die Art und Weise, wann ausgelöst wird, dass ich diese sechsstelligen Zahlen eingeben muss. Ja oder nein?
Unter anderem.
Das ist irgendwie anhangenden Dingsbums, ja.
Aber das ist doch sozusagen eine der Hauptärgernisse.
Genau, also ne, stimmt sogar. Stimmt nicht. Das steht nicht in der PSD2 drin, sondern in der technischen Durchführungsrichtlinie zur... Moment, ich hab mir das extra aufgeschrieben. Es ist die Delegierte Verordnung 218 und 389 der Kommission zur Ergänzung der Richtlinie 2366 zur Europäischen Parlamentsüber, technische Regulierungsstimmen.
Wenn ich jetzt als normaler Mensch sage, die PSD2 ist schuld, stimmt's trotzdem?
Im Bankkontext würden sie dich komisch anschnauen, sind sie nämlich dann RTS, aber ja.
Alles klar. Aber was hat sich denn jetzt verändert.
Ja, nein. Historisch gesehen. Ja. Wir haben ja kurz darüber gesprochen, dass es zwischendurch sofort Überweisung ins Leben sprang und Dinge tat, die eigentlich verboten waren. Und dann aber gerichtet.
Warte mal, verboten im Sinne von die Banken haben in ihren AGBs geschrieben, soll das nicht machen. Nicht gesetzlich verboten.
Genau, aber du hast ja den Vertrag mit der Bank geschlossen.
Ja, und deswegen konnten die Banken halt auch nicht dagegen vorgehen, weil sie wollten ihre Kunden ja nicht rauswerfen.
Genau, und dann gerichtlich festgestellt worden, dass das nicht so und so hätte. Trotzdem war es ja, hätte man es ja als wildwest bezeichnen können, weil die sind ja da, die Firma existierte da so ein bisschen in einem Vakuum.
Ja, aber hat ganz gut verdient. Die gibt es ja immer noch.
Genau, die sind halt irgendwann übernommen worden, heißen jetzt Klarna und machen noch mehr Zeugs. Ist an der Stelle aber auch erstmal in Deutschland entstanden und dann internationalisiert. In dem Vorwort zur PSD2 steht tatsächlich drin, dass sich die Kommission das angeguckt hat und dann eine Richtlinie erlassen wollte, die auch solche neu modischen Zahlungssysteme reglementiert reguliert. Und zwar haben sie dann sogar zwei Unterschiede gemacht. Das eine ist ein sogenannter Zahlungsauslöse-Dienst, also Sofortüberweisung. Und das andere ist ein reiner Kontoinformationsdienst, der keine Zahlungsauslösung, sondern Großkontoinformationen anzeigt.
Was ist da die praktikable Anwendung?
Es gibt keine. Aber sie haben halt gesagt, das sind so die Dinge, die es gibt. Und wir wollen jetzt folgende Richtlinien erlassen, um diese zu regulieren, aber gleichzeitig den bestehenden Markt weiterlaufen zu lassen. So ungefähr steht das da vorne.
Warte mal, die PSD2 ist, könnte man auch so sagen, es könnte auch für Sofortüberweisungen?
Lex Sofortüberweisung, der Begriff fiel an einigen Stellen. Auf dem Kongress hatte sich am Ende jemand gemeldet von der Firma und war, die sind selber nicht ganz zufrieden mit der Richtlinie. Wir hoffen und warten alle auf die PSD3.
Okay, aber das verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Wie genau hängt das jetzt damit zusammen?
Der, naja, ist...
Also wir waren ja gerade noch bei Tanne eingeben.
Genau. Wir waren auch bei zwei Parteien. Ja. Außer, wenn man so was wie Sofortbeweisung macht, dann kommt so eine merkwürdige Wildwest-Dritte-Partei dazwischen. Und wir sind im europäischen Kontext. In Deutschland war alles eigentlich ganz gut. Wir hatten HBCI bzw. Fintes.
Wir haben das nicht erklärt, aber es sind einfach zwei weitere Technik-Landstücke.
Genau, das ist einfach etwas, das ist das, was wir vorhin gesagt haben, das Programm, was auf deinem Rechner läuft, kann mit diesem Protokoll mit dem Bankrechner sprechen. Das nennt man dann Geschäftsvorfälle, aber halt Transaktionen, also Abrufen, Konterauszüge, Überweisungen tätigen, Lastschriften einreichen, all so ein Kram. Als standardisiertes Protokoll quasi, oder ich glaube, jede deutsche Bank unterstützt das. Die Sicherheitsmerkmale, die wir besprochen haben, PIN und TAN gelten auch dort. Hat aber den Vorteil, weil es von jeder Bank unterstützt wird, ein standardisiertes Protokoll ist, kannst du die gleiche Software mit allen Banken verwenden. Insbesondere kannst du mehrere Bankkonten in einer Software haben. Da sind wir wieder sowohl im Firmenkontext, als auch im, sagen wir mal, engagierter Privatnutzerkontext.
Aber auch Banken machen das jetzt. Letztlich dann Multibanking. Und dann kannst du in deinem Online-Banking von deiner Bank auch Konten von anderen Banken verwenden.
Genau, also das Stichwort an der Stelle Multibanking. Du kannst mehrere Banken drin haben. Das finden die alle mäßig gut oder doof. Also Sparkasse hat dann immer eine Sparkasse-App rausgegeben, die hintenrum auch nur HBCI spricht, wie alle anderen, aber man nur mit Sparkasse sprechen durfte und so weiter. Zwischendurch, und das war das, was er montags gerade sagte, gab es dann die Idee, naja, wenn wir jetzt eh schon eine Webseite haben, dann kann sich ja diese Webseite auf dem anderen Rechner einloggen. Wir haben jetzt drei Parteien eingebaut. Also das Modell Sofortüberweisung quasi erweitert oder anders angewandt. Anstatt dass ich eine Applikation auf meinem Rechner habe, die sich auf allen Banken einloggt, gebe ich meine Daten einer Webseite, die sich auf allen Banken einloggt und mir das dann alles auf der Webseite anzeigt.
Warte, irgendjemand hat das Cloudbanking genannt.
Ich glaube, das kannst du dir noch schützen lassen.
Ich glaube die Nähe zu GeCloud ist da zu stark.
Genau, das haben sich zumindest Leute ausgedacht, dass das eine Möglichkeit sein könnte, so was anzuwenden. Nicht, dass mir bekannt wäre, dass das irgendjemand je getan hätte. Genau, das ist dann wieder die Kategorie. Du sollst halt die Bank Webseite nicht verlassen, weil da bieten sie dir auch immer gleich an, ein Portfolio zu eröffnen und Aktien zu kaufen. Also womit sie wirklich Geld verdienen. Solange du auf der Bank Webseite bleibst, sind sie glücklich. Das heißt, sie bieten dir auch selbstlos an, andere Banken dort einzubinden.
Ach, das ist doch mal nett von denen. Und das alles soll durch PSD2 in Bahnen gelenkt werden?
Genau, weil wenn wir das jetzt so machen, wie die Deutschen das bisher hatten über HBCI, dann musst du halt die Zugangsdaten bei wem auch immer eingeben, der halt nicht deine Bank ist. Wenn man sich das im europäischen Vergleich anguckt, die hatten niemals HBCI, dann musste man dann ganz komische Sachen machen und Web Scraper bauen, d.h. ein automatisiertes Programm lockt sich auf der Webseite an und guckt sich quasi die Webseite, die zurückkommt, an, um herauszufinden, wo da die Tabellen sind und was in den Tabellen drin steht.
Sozusagen die studentische Hilfskraft unter den Softwareprogrammen.
Ja, die dann entsprechend oft bricht, weil Banken wollen ja auch ab und zu mal relaunchen und ein neues Design und alles 2 cm nach links und dann funktioniert nichts mehr. PSD2 soll dafür sorgen, dass diese Funktionalität so ähnlich aussieht und zwar für alle Europäer verfügbar wird. Allerdings auch nur genau diese Funktionalität. Was ich mir dazu von Hagen da wäre. Ja, das Konzept, dass du eine Software auf deinem Rechner hast, ist nicht mehr vorgesehen. Das hatten die anderen ja nie. Die anderen hatten ja nie Software auf ihrem Rechner, die alles konnte, sondern die mussten sich immer manuell händisch bei ihrer Banking-Webseite einloggen, haben dann mehrere Tabs aufgemacht, wenn sie Überblicke über mehrere Konten machen wollten vielleicht. Sondern die PSD2 sieht nur vor, dass es jetzt Dienstleister geben kann, Dienstleister geben kann, die sich in deinem Auftrag mit der Bank verbinden und von der Bank Kontoinformation erhalten. Wow.
Insbesondere soll das jetzt ja Fintech fördern. Das brauchen wir nämlich dringend in der EU.
Genau. Was das jetzt, also man könnte jetzt auch Wirtschaftsförderung über die Hintertür sagen, aber das wäre jetzt die sarkastische Betrachtungsweise. Die andere Betrachtungsweise ist halt, man hat niemals vorgesehen oder wusste nicht, dass es das überhaupt gibt, weiß ich nicht, eine von diesen Varianten. Sondern es sind jetzt reguliert, zugelassen und verpflichtend, dass es möglich sein muss, dass Dienstleister, die einen Service betreiben, einen Zahlungsdienst oder einen Kontoinformationsdienst, heißt das dann, von deinem Konto Informationen kriegen.
Warte mal, also ich verstehe das richtig. Die Banken sind jetzt verpflichtet, es möglich zu machen, dass eine dritte Partei auf das Konto zugreifen kann.
Genau.
Aber die Banken sind nicht mehr verpflichtet, mir als Person die automatisierte Verarbeitung auf mein Konto zu machen.
Genau, die Verpflichtung hatten sie nie. Sie haben das quasi aus persönlicher Friede, Freude, Kundenfreundlichkeit gemacht. Wenn sie jetzt aber die andere Infrastruktur, die Verpflichtende betreiben müssen, haben schon einige Banken angekündigt, warum sollen wir den anderen Scheiß noch warten? Das kostet doch nur Geld.
Das verstehe ich nicht. Also ich bin hier mit der Bank, die Konto hat. Es gibt jetzt eine dritte Firma, die bietet mir einen Dienst an, hier ich kann mich um alle deine Konten kümmern. Und die PSD2 sagt, das muss auch möglich sein. Aber da kann ich ja genauso gut sagen, ich will ja selber dieser Dienst sein.
Genau, der Dienst kannst du nicht sein. Genau, es gibt keine Möglichkeit, wie du das selber machen kannst, ohne einen Dienst zu benutzen nach PSD2.
Aber also ein Dienst ist ja, also in Worten des einfach Menschen, ist ja eine Firma, die eine Software betreibt. Dann müsste es auch möglich sein, dass ich diese Software selber baue.
Oh ja, ja, ist möglich. Du musst bloß die zertifizieren, also nicht zertifizieren lassen, sondern du musst dich registrieren. Du musst ein Eigenkapital vorweisen von 50.000 Euro, eine Berufshaftpflichtversicherung. Du benötigst ein qualifiziertes elektronisches Signaturzertifikat, was noch mal mit so um die 2000 Euro pro Jahr zu Buche schlägt. Und ich glaube, das war's. Du musst dich registrieren.
Ja, du musst zugelassen werden. Und wenn du jetzt fragst, was ist jetzt mit diesem Fintes HBCI Zugang, der ist jetzt auch anders seit September. Da bin ich drauf reingefallen sozusagen. Du kannst ja unter Linux mit Akku Banking oder so was bisher oft noch auf dein Konto zugreifen. Das ist dann eben über HBCI Fintes mit Nutzernahme, Passwort. Und ab und zu kommt halt eine TAN-Abfrage. Aber seit September musst du auch da eine Softwarekennung mit übermitteln. Das heißt, wenn ich eine Bibliothek schreiben möchte oder ein eigenes Skript, um für mich privat selber auf mein Konto zuzugreifen, zum Beispiel um einmal die Woche meinen Kontostand irgendwo wegzuschreiben oder die Transaktion, muss ich mich beim zentralen Kreditausschuss melden und muss mich als Anbieter oder als Software registrieren und für dieses eine Skript eine ID beantragen. Und so alle 10 Tage ungefähr sagen die auch und dann bekomme ich dann, wenn ich da ein Fax hin schicke, eine ID zurück und die muss ich dann in jede Transaktion, die ich per HBCI oder FTS auslösen möchte, mit übertragen. Und diese ID ist jetzt nicht etwa so was fancy wie ein Zertifikat. Nein, sie haben mir erklärt, das ist total einfach gelöst. Das ist einfach nur ein String, sprich wirklich eine ID, eine Nummer, was auch immer. Und mit dieser Nummer zeigen sie sich dann im Online-Banking den Kunden an, welche Software diese Transaktion durchgeführt hat.
Genau.
Also ich kann natürlich auch einfach die ID von Star Money aus der Binary kopieren und die da übermitteln. Dann steht halt in meinem Online-Banking, dass Star Money das gemacht hat. Aber sie behalten sich vor, anhand dieser ID Musbrauch zu erkennen und dann einzelne Software zu sperren.
Verstärkte Transparenz, sowohl Pflichten als auch Informationen für den Endkunden. Der soll sehen, welche Dienstleister und welche Software auf sein Konto zugegriffen hat oder zugreifen kann. Und sofern der HBCI, also sofern der Weg, dass ich eine Software auf meinem eigenen Rechner ausführe, noch möglich ist, muss diese Software zumindest mal gelistet sein mit einem Verantwortlichen und Ansprechpartner und halt ihre eigene Identifikation übermitteln. Aber das kannst du auch als Endbenutzer, das habe ich gemacht. Also für meine eigene Software, das ist unkompliziert, schreib mal eine Mail hin, komm ein paar Tage später eine Mail zurück, wir haben sie jetzt aufgenommen als Open Source Entwickler, Name Henrik Plötz, folgende Software, folgende ID.
Aber das ermöglicht ja vor allen Dingen auch noch, dass ich mir eine Software einfach kaufe, die das macht.
Ja, genau, das geht weiterhin, sofern die Bank den Zugang noch möglich hat. Genau, sofern die Bank den Zugang noch anbietet.
Was mich halt stutzig gemacht hat, Montagsstopp halt, ich hatte, stopp. Also wenn die Bank das noch anbietet, das heißt also zwischen der die Art und Weise, wie es technisch gelöst ist, dass diese Dritten auf Bankdaten zugreifen und die Art und Weise, wie eine Software, die ich mir kaufe, zugreife, besteht ein Unterschied?
Ja, das war das, was ich sagte. Die Software ist weiterhin der alte Weg, der 2018 bestand.
Aber ich verstehe nicht ganz sozusagen die technische Erklärung für warum die Software nicht auch einfach die...
Als Dienstleister registriert ist und den Weg benutzt nach PSD2. Genau. Das war in meiner Auflösung ganz hinten drin. Du brauchst ein qualifizierendes elektronisches Signaturzertifikat. Du musst dich quasi mit diesem Zertifikat der Bank gegenüber ausweisen als zugelassener Dienstleister. Dieses Zertifikat hängt an einem privaten Schlüssel, der privat bleiben muss. Den darfst du halt nicht freigeben. Das heißt, insbesondere darfst du ihn natürlich nicht bei deiner Software mitliefern auf den Kundenrechner.
Also die Idee ist sozusagen, dass Banken nur eine begrenzte Anzahl privater Schlüssel mit einer begrenzten Anzahl von diesen Zertifizierten stellen.
Nee, die ist nicht begrenzt, aber...
Nee, nicht begrenzt in dem Sinne von, dass man nicht viele machen könnte, aber im Sinne von nicht jeder einzelne Nutzer soll so ein Ding haben, sondern nur noch Institutionen.
Genau, nur der Dienstleister, nur die Institution, kriegt das Zertifikat und die dürfen das halt auch nicht weitergeben, weil wenn sie es weitergeben, wird es gesperrt. Das darf nur einer haben.
Ich muss kurz politisch fragen, war dann hinter der Schaffung der PSD2 die Idee, also gibt es Parteien, die ein Interesse daran haben, diese Dienste zu fördern oder abzuschaffen, dass einzelne Menschen Software benutzt, die auf dem eigenen Rechner läuft?
Kann ich nicht beantworten, aber es gibt ja immer die zwei Varianten, Bösartigkeit oder Unwissenheit. Ich würde einfach darauf tippen, dass niemand auf dem Schirm hatte, dass es auch noch Leute gibt, die Software auf ihrem eigenen Rechner ausführen, diese Steinzeitmenschen, die keine Clouddienste haben.
So ist das also.
Das heißt also, es kann wirklich nur ein Clouddienst diesen Dienst anbieten. Du hast vorhin gefragt, Kontra und Informationsdienst, was ist die Idee dabei?
Mir fällt keine ein. Diese Zweiparteienkommunikation ist über kurz oder lang? Naja, nie.
Die ist halt nur in Deutschland möglich und nur solange die Banken das nicht abschalten.
Und sie ist in Zukunft noch, ich rede zu sagen erst mal nur vom Konzept 1 zu 1, ist noch möglich, wenn ich mich von Hand in ein Webinterface einlogge.
Genau, das kannst du weiterhin simulieren.
Automatisieren geht sozusagen nicht. Oder nur schwer.
Genau, und insbesondere sieht eine Automatisierung nicht anders aus als ein Angriff. Also Banken könnten anfangen, automatisierte Anfragen explizit abzuschalten.
Also auf jeden Fall gibt es demnächst Platz im Markt für...
Genau, ganz großartig. Rein zufällig entstehen ja sehr viele Firmen, die nichts weiter vorzuweisen haben als eine Zertifizierung und Zulassung als das ein oder das andere. Und gerade noch Geschäftsmodelle suchen.
Also mal abgesehen davon, dass wir vielleicht noch mal drüber reden können, wie ärgerlich das alles ist. Macht es Online-Banking sicherer?
Nein, unsicherer.
Warum? Warum das denn jetzt? Also weil Dritte im Spiel sind?
Ja, nicht nur, das ist das eine. Zum anderen ist mindestens die Unsicherheit im Sinne von menschlicher Unsicherheit. Du hast, das fand ich am Anfang ganz merkwürdig, du hast es nicht mitgekriegt, dass es eingeführt wurde. Ich habe sehr viel Spam gekriegt. Hier, Sie haben noch in den Medien sicherlich erfahren, dass es eine Umstellung des Sicherheitsmerkmals gibt. Bitte loggen Sie sich hier noch mal ein und geben noch einmal Pin und Tann ein. Perfekte Gelegenheit, um Phishing zu verschicken.
Es kann sein, dass mein interner Filter, wenn irgendwas mit Banking per Mail kommt, ich sage ja ja.
Genau. Aber diesmal stand ja in den Medien, stand ja in der Zeitung. Genau, du hast jetzt mehr Parteien drin.
Entweder werde ich alt oder... Ich habe es wirklich einfach ausgewendet.
Alles, was den Benutzern mehr nervt, sorgt für weniger Sicherheit. Weil er dann eher dazu neigt, Fehler zu machen. Wie gesagt, wir kommen wahrscheinlich noch drauf auf die Ausnahmen. Der Benutzer weiß jetzt ja nicht, was passieren wird. Das mentale Modell funktioniert nicht mehr. Brauche ich jetzt eine Tanne oder nicht?
Vorhin, als du das gesagt hast, mit diesem Nicht-Immers-Tanne, dachte ich so, na ja, aber ist doch eigentlich auch egal.
Aber Vorhersehbarkeit ist eines der Kernmerkmale eines guten User Interfaces.
Ja, jetzt wo du es so formuliert hast und nach einer Stunde später macht das total Sinn, dass das eine doofe Idee ist.
Und dein Kreditkartenerlebnis, für Kreditkarten gilt das jetzt auch. Die müssen jetzt auch das mit irgendwie sowas Ähnlichem machen. Das war das, was ich anfangs sagte, das ist noch nicht überall durchgesetzt. Die Kreditkarten haben das nämlich alle noch nicht hingekriegt. Das heißt, der Teil der PSD2, der für Kreditkarten zuständig ist, ist jetzt erst mal bis Dezember, glaube ich, ausgesetzt. Gucken Sie mal, ob sie es hingekriegt haben. Außer die Deutsche Bahn. Die Deutsche Bahn ist die einzige, die wirklich zum Stichtag im Wesentlichen alles abgeschaltet hat, was nicht ordentliche Kreditkarten sind an der Stelle. Das war ein bisschen absurd.
Also diese Nummer, dass man, wenn man eine Kreditkarte benutzt, jetzt auch noch mal so einen Code generieren muss, ist auch ein Effekt von PSD2?
Nein. Also das hatten sie vorher schon. Das heißt dann Mastercard, Secure Code. Genau, das war halb optional. Das war dann, hintenrum sind Kreditkarten. Ja, eigentlich war Kreditkarten ja nur, du gibst deine Nummer ein. Und dann machen die ganz viel Mathematik und Risikoberechnung hintenrum und dann lassen sie die Zahlung zu oder auch nicht. Akzeptieren so und so viel Mikroprozente an Betrug und schlagen das auf die Gebühren drauf. Dann gab es irgendwann das Verfahren...
Weil das jetzt gerade sehr schnell geht. Das ist das Geschäftsmodell von Kreditkarten.
Das ist das eigentliche Geschäftsmodell von Kreditkarten. Und dann gab es irgendwann mal etwas, das heißt 3D Secure. Markennamen sind Verified by Visa oder Mastercard Secure Code. Das 3D steht für drei Domains. Das sind irgendwie die Domains Issuer, Acquirer und Merchant.
Das heißt der Händler, der Kartenausgeber und...
Und der Kartenakzeptierender. Also das sind immer zwei Parteien dabei. Der Kunde ist an der Stelle nicht genannt. Das macht es halt für die drei Domains sicherer.
Wer braucht so einen Kunden?
Genau. Und das ist halt die Nummer mit zusätzlichem Passwort oder so eingeben. Das heißt es wird einfach noch... Es passieren zwei Sachen. Die AGB ändern sich und du musst ein zusätzliches Passwort für die Zahlung eingeben. Die AGB ändern sich so, dass wenn das Passwort eingegeben ist, bist du schuld. Oder der Händler. Also aber in keinem Fall ist der Kreditkartenherausgeber mehr schuld.
Schön.
Das heißt die Sache, mit denen wir schlagen die Betrugsprozente einfach auf die Gebühren auf, ändern sich plötzlich in Reingewinnen. Weil die Gebühren haben sich nicht geändert dadurch. Das war das Vorherige. Dazu gibt es auch Vorträge.
Sind wir jetzt am Punkt, wo wir sagen, wir sollten den Kapitalismus mal anzünden?
Er brennt glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube die Banken uns entsprechen.
Vielleicht sollten wir da mal ein eigenes Chaosradio zu machen.
Ist das B1? Das war das Vorherige. Dazu gibt es auch alte Vorträge, ich glaube von 2010. Schauen wir uns nochmal nach. Ross Anderson war es glaube ich. Aus Cambridge. How not to design a payment system. Die hatten nämlich sehr viele lustige Fehler bei der Implementierung davon, die es wieder netto unsicherer gemacht haben. Was es aber tatsächlich hat, ist jetzt neuerdings ein Tannenmechanismus. Und die PSD2 schreibt vor, dass der jetzt da sein muss. Das heißt, das wird jetzt verpflichtend eingeschaltet. Bisher war dieser Mechanismus optional. Der Händler konnte sagen, will ich oder will ich nicht. Wenn will ich nicht, dann hat er halt gegebenenfalls höhere Prozente gezahlt. Und jetzt ist halt verpflichtend.
Warte mal.
Hendrik, seit wann denn?
Auch seit 14. September.
Das ist witzig, weil bei AliExpress merke ich da nichts von.
Genau, das war das, was ich sagte. Eigentlich gilt es seit 14. September. Da aber kaum jemand von den Online-Händlern das hingekriegt hat, das zu implementieren, ist der Teil ausgesetzt, bis sie sich nochmal melden.
Warte mal. Also. Kurze Nachfrage. Wenn ich bei PayPal meine Kreditkarte hinterlegt habe, dann werde ich nicht jedes Mal nach so einem Ding gefragt.
Wiederkehrende Zahlungen sind nur eine eigene Kategorie.
Wiederkehrende Zahlungen sind eine eigene Kategorie. Das ginge theoretisch auch bei einem Händler. Also wenn ein Händler einmal nach einer Kreditkarte von mir fragt.
Genau, der muss bei dem ersten Mal die TAN oder was auch immer abfragen. Bei weiteren kann es sein, dass er nicht muss.
Genau, und er kann mich dann fragen, willst du, dass ich die Kreditkartendaten speichere?
Das hat keinen Einfluss darauf. Das sind unterschiedliche Informationen.
Aber wenn er die Daten nicht speichert, kann er ja nicht bei der Dichtung... Dann kann es passieren, dass ich keine...
Genau, dann kann es sein, dass da ist dann irgendwie Risikosteuerung hinten drin, die rechnet dann irgendwelche Prozente aus und sagt dann, ja muss oder muss nicht.
Dass mir das bei PayPal noch nie passiert ist, heißt das, dass PayPal das generell nicht machen muss? Oder heißt das, dass meine Kreditkarte so eingestuft wurde, dass die Ausgabene in der Stelle gesagt hat, du, wenn PayPal nochmal kommt bei dir, das weiß ich nicht, ich glaube aber mal, dass PayPal da ausreichend Marktmacht hat, dass sie die schlimmsten Fall-Sonderverträge haben. Und man kann ja bei PayPal auch direkt ein Konto...
Genau, das ist der einfache Fall. Deutsche Lastenschrift ist trivial.
Weil jetzt ist mein Verdacht gerade, der Gewinner der PSD2 ist PayPal. Weil momentan ist es ja so, wenn ich mit Kreditkarte überweise, muss ich zweimal 6-stellige Zahlen irgendwo hineintragen.
Das ist nur bei deiner Bank so. Ach, wirklich? Ja. Also ich hab deine Beschreibung gehört. Die erste 6-stellige Zahl war zum Einloggen in das Online-Banking. Das haben wir schon gehört. Das ist nicht immer so. Und die zweite war tatsächlich die Verified-by-Visa- oder Mastercard-Secure-Code-TAN. Es gibt Banken, die machen die erste TAN nur manchmal. Und die zweite TAN zum Beispiel gar nicht, weil man mit Fingerabdruck freigeben kann.
Ich glaube, es gibt noch Banken, die machen es so, dass sie nicht an diesem Verified-by-Visa mitmachen, sondern du musst eine TAN auf der Online-Backing-Webseite nochmal eingeben, die dann den Kreditkartenzahlfall gibt.
Genau, das ist ja das, was sie sagen. Aber das heißt sozusagen, auf jeden Fall ist mit Kreditkartenzahlen tendenziell, auch wenn es nur mein Finger auf dem Gerät liegen ist, komplizierter als vorher.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Es wird in Zukunft noch viel schlimmer.
Während Paypal, die ja auch immer fragen, möchtest du gleich eingeloggt bleiben? Dann ist es noch viel einfacher, wenn das sozusagen Null Schritte braucht.
Genau, das ist tatsächlich richtig. Paypal hat, das sagte ich in meinem Vortrag, ich wurde leicht korrigiert, aber Paypal hat eigentlich keine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung. Sie haben sowas, das bewerben sie nicht so richtig, und das läuft noch manchmal so ein bisschen. Aber es gibt ja zum Beispiel keine SMS-Code oder sonst was bei Paypal, weil die einfach durchgerechnet haben. Benutzereinfachheit versus, da sind da halt zwei Promille Betrug, meine Güte. Also die Betrugsraten, die ich gehört habe von Visa, das waren halt absurd geringe Zahlen. Das ist alles, das will man nicht mehr. Das fällt nicht weiter auf. Wenn man es hochmolektiziert, sind es zwar große absolute Zahlen, aber in Prozenten in Relation zu den Kreditkartengebühren ist das ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein. Also Kreditkartengebühren sind richtig groß. Mindestens 0, 3% plus ein paar Cent. Und wenn du eine Firmenkreditkarte hast, 1, 8%.
Okay, aber das heißt, Paper profitiert davon, könnte man vermuten. Unter anderem wäre noch die Anbieter dieser Cloud-Dienste.
Genau, also ZeroPay bzw. P-Direct können profitieren. Natürlich die sogenannten Fintechs, also irgendwelche Start-ups, die irgendwas mit irgendwas so ähnlich wie Banken machen, die teilweise den Vorteil haben, dass sie keine Banken-IT haben, sondern modernere Infrastruktur, die also mit Apps angefangen haben und nicht nachgerüstet. Da ist dann tatsächlich der Komfort des zweiten Faktors oder der sogenannten starken Kunden-Authentifizierung besser, dass da nur noch Fingerabdruck ist oder FaceID sogar im besten Fall. Es hat halt etabliert eine neue Art von Anbieter, eine neue Art von Firma, die plötzlich verpflichtet ist, ein neuer Gatekeeper, der dazwischen sitzt. Das ist einmal Sofortüberweisung. Auf der anderen Seite... Ach, den Teil hab ich noch nicht erzählt.
Warte mal, ich frage mich gerade, ist eine Konsequenz aus der ganzen Geschichte, was jetzt schon häufiger gesagt wurde, was so klingt, ist, es gibt also die Chance, dass eine dritte Partei beteiligt ist bei diesen Dingern. Also wenn ich in Zukunft online banking mache, ist die Chance, dass eine dritte Partei beteiligt ist, relativ hoch. Meine Vermutung ist...
Wenn du es nicht direkt auf der Bankwerkseite machst.
Genau, wenn ich es nicht direkt mache. Meine Vermutung ist, ich klicke jedes Mal eine AGB an, die sagen, wir nehmen deine Daten auch gleich mit.
Ja, ja, genau. Also das will ich ausführen. Also ich habe das die Lüge von der dritten Partei genannt, weil da immer von der dritten Partei die Rede ist. Aber es keinen Anwendungsfall gibt, wo es nur drei Parteien sind.
Wer macht noch?
Ganz kurz, mir ist eine Möglichkeit eingefallen, für diese nur lesende dritte Partei, diese Dienstleister. Kreditsvergabestellen natürlich, die können ja darüber wunderbar prüfen, wie deine Einkünfte und so sind und auch überwachen in Zukunft.
Komme ich gerade, genau. Also es gibt keinen Anwendungsfall, wo nur drei Parteien beteiligt sind, also keinen sinnvollen. Bestenfalls noch das Multibanking. Du kannst auf einer Webseite sehen, das ist halt du, also dein Rechner, die Webseite und deine Bank. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie oft machst du das, dass du nicht auf deine Bank-Webseite gehst, sondern auf eine andere Webseite, um deinen Kontostand zu sehen. So ein bisschen. Während in den Anwendungsfällen, wo ich normalerweise eine Software ausführen würde, wie zum Beispiel bei meiner Firma, Lohnbuchhaltung, jetzt einmal bitte Löhne überweisen, geht nicht mehr direkt. Sondern die kommuniziert jetzt mit einem Server des Herstellers der Software. Nice. Ich authentifiziere mich da gegenüber mit meinem Online-Konto, ich hab da so einen Servicevertrag. Die sind aber kein zertifizierter Zahlungsdienstleister, sondern die kommunizieren mit einer anderen Firma, die dann mit meiner Bank redet. Das ist jetzt die vierte Partei. Also das, was eigentlich die dritte Partei ist, ist die vierte Partei, weil es selten vorkommt, dass es nur drei sind. Und da ist zum Beispiel einer, die Fin-API GmbH, eine Tochter der Schufer Holding GmbH. Jetzt sind wir bei einem Kreditvergabestell.
Also das heißt ja auch, die Stelle war auch in einem Vortrag, da stellst du auch immer diese Fin-API, und mir schaust du dich im Kopf, ist Fin-API im Prinzip das WhatsApp des Finanzmarktes? Im Sinne der, da fallen sehr viele Daten und Metadaten an, die man ganz prima machen kann, um Dinge zu berechnen?
Genau, aber sie sind hoch und heilig und Datenschutz und DSGVO.
Ist ja die Schufer auch bekannt für.
Und der Grund, warum es die gibt, das war der Teil, den ich vorhin vergessen habe, zu erzählen. Du hattest es korrekt wiedergegeben, Banken sind verpflichtet zu ermöglichen, dass eine andere Partei darauf zugreift. Es ist aber an keiner Stelle gesagt, wie sie es ausgestalten müssen. Das heißt, jede Bank kann prinzipiell ein eigenes Interface bauen. Wenn jetzt jemand schon mal den Aufwand getrieben hat, diese Registrierung, Zulassung und so weiter für das Zertifikat zu machen, muss er erstmal die Schnittstelle implementieren, um mit einer Bank zu reden. Kann im schlimmsten Fall aber nur mit dieser einen Bank reden. Das heißt, wenn er mit einer anderen Bank reden möchte, kann es sein, dass er nochmal neu programmieren muss, eine neue Schnittstelle. Bei der dritten Bank eine dritte. Technisch gesehen wäre es tatsächlich laut Richtlinie so, dass jede Bank was anderes haben könnte. Praktisch haben die Banken auch alle keinen Bock, das zu tun, sondern die kaufen sich die Komponente ein.
Bei FinApi?
Nee, das ist eine andere Firma. Ich glaube der Bankenverlag macht das. Irgendwie kommt man auf fünf oder sechs verschiedene. Das heißt es gibt mindestens fünf oder sechs verschiedene Interfaces, die Banken nach außen anbieten.
Und FinApi bietet an, wir kümmern uns um darum. Und dann könnt ihr nur zu uns kommen. Aber sind wir nicht dann bei fünf im Zweifelsfall?
Ja, schlimmsten Fall. Normalerweise hast du halt einen Dienstleister, der irgendwas wirklich tun... Du. Der Dienstleister, der irgendwas wirklich tun möchte. Der dann FinApi benutzt, der dann mit deiner Bank redet.
Toll.
Weil der Dienstleister, der wirklich was tun möchte, hat halt keine Lust, alle Apis zu implementieren.
Ja, natürlich nicht.
Und nimmt diesen neuen Gatekeeper, FinApi, oder ich weiß nicht, technisch gesehen gibt's Mitbewerber, aber praktisch gesehen nicht so.
Der der Schufa gehört, das muss man sich auch noch mit dem Maulter Zunge zergehen lassen.
Die sich mal die Mühe gemacht haben, aus reinem Eigennutz oder Geschäftsinteresse alle möglichen Banken apisch zu implementieren. Weil das die Alternative wäre, du hast nur zwei oder drei implementiert, weil du nicht mehr Entwicklerzeit hattest. Und dann kommt ein Kunde und sagt, ich bin aber bei folgender Bank. Schade.
Schade.
Ich hab jetzt mal eine Frage. Ich hab den Podcast selber nicht gehört, aber ich wurde von Bekannten vorhin angesprochen. Was denn dagegen spricht, dass man jetzt eine Open Chaos Finances GmbH gründet, da ein bisschen Geld crowdfunded und selber eine vernünftige API nach außen anbietet und sich dann dazwischen setzt. So als Non-Profit.
Du kannst es nicht als Non-Profit betreiben, weil es halt wirklich teuer ist. Du kannst, ich muss gerade überlegen, du hast irgendwelche Verpflichtungen, was die Kundendaten angeht. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es möglich ist, das dem konform zu machen.
Wenn du eine GGmbH machst, die halt nur keinen Gewinn erwirtschaften darf, aber aus Transaktionsgebühren sich halt finanziert gerade so.
Aber das Ziel wäre dann quasi im erweiterten sozialen Umfeld eine Institution zu haben, der man mehr vertraut als in anderen Mitspielern?
Genau, als der Fin-API, also quasi ein Fin-API-Klon in GGmbH. Wie gesagt, ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ich glaube, du kannst, da weiß ich es nicht. Es kann sein, oder ich würde vermuten, dass du die Daten nicht so weiter vergeben darfst oder halt entsprechend auch die gleichen Anforderungen an die deine Kunden stellen musst. Wahrscheinlich wird das dann transitiv.
Also aufwendig wahrscheinlich auch einfach, ne?
Was heißt transitiv in dem Fall?
Na, dass du bist ja als zugelassener Dienstleister verpflichtet folgende, was auch immer. Und wenn du aber das nur als durchreiche Posten betreibst, dann kann es sein, dass einfach alle Leute dich benutzen.
Jetzt verstehe ich das erst sozusagen. Also die, was Mutags eigentlich meint, es gibt sozusagen eine Firma, die tut so, als wäre sie fin ab. Ja, aber da darf dann jeder alles, aber das wird dann schwierig, weil dann würde die Firma in Haftung genommen und okay.
War übrigens ein Kongressvortrag.
Naja, nun sitzen wir an dieser Stelle, dass die neuen Verpflichtungen, damit haben wir ja eingestiegen, was die starke Kundenautentifizierung angeht, auch auf alle anderen Zugangswege zur Bank anzuwenden sind. Nicht nur auf die PSD2. Also auf die Wege, die nach der PSD2 neu sind, sondern auch auf die alten. Was halt dazu führt, dass alle alten Workflows kaputtgehen. Und zwar nicht nur an der Stelle, sondern unter anderem steht da auch drin, dass jetzt der Zugreifende persönlich identifiziert werden muss. Das trifft dich jetzt nicht so, aber wenn ich ein Konto habe von einem Verein oder von einer Firma, war das bisher häufig so, dass man einfach Kontonummer und PIN hatte.
Ja.
Die kriegt halt jeder der Vorstände, der Konto lesen muss, das ist mir egal, und der Kassierer kriegt dann halt das TAN Medium.
Also die Chipkarte oder das Lesegräfer-TAN-Liste, was auch immer.
Genau, dann weiß man halt nur, der darf schreiben und alle dürfen lesen. Aber das geht halt nicht mehr, weil es müssen immer persönliche Accounts sein. Das heißt, wir haben einen riesigen Aufwand gehabt, dass irgendwie jeder, der Kontozugriff braucht, jetzt einen neuen persönlichen Account braucht. Dann die entsprechenden Rechte, auf die diesen Account konfiguriert werden müssen.
Aber da muss ich schon mal ganz ehrlich sagen, ist das nicht eigentlich auch the right way to do it?
Es ist eigentlich der richtige Weg. Aber die Banken waren natürlich völlig überfordert. Ich hab das bei meinen Vereinskonten gehabt. Da hat die Postbank gesagt, übrigens demnächst Umstellung und so und hier. Klicken Sie mal hier, die Umstellung kann man direkt online vornehmen. Dann hab ich das gemacht und dann stand da, ja, geht nicht. Also hab ich das Problem auf die Runterlage gelegt und erst mal ignoriert und hab am 12. oder am 13. September meine Zugangsdaten gekriegt. Hier ist übrigens ihr persönlicher Account.
Aha, und wo sind die anderen vier?
Die anderen haben auch einen gekriegt. Aber die Bebrechtigung war nicht drauf. Ich hatte jetzt plötzlich nur noch Leserechte.
Und niemand hatte Schreibrechte?
Niemand hatte mehr Schreibrechte. Man kann dann anrufen und sagen, ach so, ja, nee. Okay, ich schalte Ihnen noch mal den alten Account für vier Wochen frei. Während der Zeit kümmern Sie sich darum, wieder Schreibrechte zu kriegen.
Du hast dich doch darum gekümmert, Schreibrechte zu kriegen.
Nein, nein, das benötigt nämlich doppelt Unterschriebene und Dingsbums und man muss halt ein Formular ausfüllen, um das Berechtigungsmanagement anzustoßen. Was dann von zwei Vorstandsmitgliedern unterschrieben werden muss. Und bitte delegieren Sie folgende Rechte auf Dingsbums. Was dann allerdings auch bei einer Bank verarbeitet werden muss. Also das ist dann die Engstelle neuerdings geworden, weil alle das gleichzeitig gemacht haben. Ich hatte das Problem, dass ich dieses Formular jetzt runtergeladen habe von der Website. Sie haben es mir an der Hotline gesagt, wo ich das Formular runterladen kann. Gar kein Problem. Ausfüllen, unterschreiben lassen, gar kein Thema. Jetzt möchte ich Ihnen das Formular gerne per E-Mail zurückschicken.
Ja.
Aber auch in deren Mails, die man mir gesagt hat, aufgrund der hohen Anzahl an betrügerischen E-Mails, die im Umlauf sind, werden manche Mails abgelehnt. Wir können Ihre E-Mail leider nicht annehmen. Also die Postbank lädt Kundenmails ab wegen der hohen Anzahl betrügerischer Mails, die Kunden erhalten. Das hat dann also an der Stelle nicht funktioniert. Da hab ich noch mal angerufen, da haben sie mir eine Faxnummer genannt und dann hab ich das gefaxt. Das Formular.
Also sollte PSD2 nicht Fortschritt bringen?
Ja, in Deutschland nicht. Genau, also in Deutschland bringt es Rückschritt allen anderen Fortschritt.
Ist es so.
Wie gesagt, war ja nicht alles schlecht in 2018, in Deutschland zumindest.
Ja, aber ist es wirklich so zu sagen, dass die Situation in der Rest-EU so katastrophal war, dass das jetzt ein großer Fortschritt ist?
Ja, also die hatten halt einfach dieses Konzept des Multibanking nicht. Wie immer ist ein neues Wort.
Ich mein ansonsten guck dir mal die USA an, da ist es noch schlimmer.
Wieso, wie ist es da?
Da kannst du glaube ich teilweise nicht mal online von Bank zu Bank überweisen, aber ich bin in Details echt nicht gut.
Ja, also das haben sie leicht verbessert, aber in Europa gibt es so ein Interbankensystem, das heißt es gibt irgendwie diese, es gibt eine zentrale Stelle, wo dann Clearing zwischen den Banken stattfindet. Das heißt dieser SEPA, der Einheitliche Zahlungsraum funktioniert, die Amerikaner haben das nicht. Da ist am besten noch, wenn jemand die Überweisung abtippen muss. Teilweise zumindest bis vor einiger Zeit war das noch so, dass du zwar im Onlinebank eine Überweisung eingibst. Das führt dann aber zu, dass die Bank einen Scheck ausschickt und der anderen Bank per Post schickt. Also du wunderst dich manchmal auf, wenn du Zahlungsinformationen eingeben musst. Eigentlich brauchst du im SEPA-Raum nur die IBAN. Vielleicht auch die DIPIC. Häufig hast du in diesen Formularen aber auch noch Adresse der Bank und Dingsbund. Man fragt sich immer warum. Das kommt aus diesem Raum, wo tatsächlich solche Zahlungen per Postweg stattgefunden haben und noch stattfinden.
Ich würde aber gerne nach Europa zurückkehren und mal fragen, wenn jetzt, wir sind jetzt bei diesen, sagen wir mindestens vier Parteien, wer ist denn eigentlich schuld, wenn das schief geht?
Bei der Kunde, oder?
Ja, aber ich glaube das geht nicht schief per Definition.
Ist das so?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Moment, steht da was zu Haftungsfragen?
Ich würde vermuten, sie machen es so wie jetzt auch. Wenn es schief geht, wird es in den Teppich gekehrt, der Schaden von der Bank übernommen. Weil wenn sie grobe Fahrlässigkeit erkennen, können sie das dem Kunden geben. Ansonsten, wenn es das System ist, das kaputt ist, dann ist es billiger, den Schaden selber zu übernehmen.
Genau, ich vermute mal, das ist einfach im bisherigen Framework abgedeckt, wer schuld ist, Fahrlässigkeit oder auch nicht. Ach so, es gibt aber tatsächlich noch eins. Die Bank ist verpflichtet, da die API, der HPSD2 nach außen hin mit derselben Verfügbarkeit verfügbar zu machen, wie das Interface, was sie ihren eigenen Kunden zur Verfügung stellen. Also Fremdanbieter müssen mindestens den gleichen Zugang erhalten, wie Bankeigene Kunden. Falls eine Bank das nicht schafft, sind Fremdanbieter berechtigt, quasi kontawidrig das Interface zu benutzen, dass die Bank eigene Kunden benutzen. Also das Web Scraping ist erlaubt, wenn die PSD2-AP ausfällt, das ist der sogenannte Fallback-Modus, Notfallmodus. Und es ist definiert, dass der ausgefallen ist, wenn er, ich glaube, drei Anfragen nacheinander innerhalb von 30 Sekunden nicht beantwortet hat oder so. Das war das mit den vorherigen Deadlines. Sie haben ja gesprochen, wann es um die Betriebne geht. Am 14. September ist es in Betrieb gegangen. Banken müssen die PSD2-AP drei Monate am Stück anbieten, funktionierend, wenn sie von dieser Vollberg-Richtlinie gerne ausgenommen werden möchten. Das heißt, sie hätten im September, Juli, Juni schon die PSD2-AP in Betrieb haben müssen, um die drei Monate zu erreichen, um von dieser Ausnahmeregelung Gebrauch zu machen.
Dass es nicht passiert?
Was auch kaum jemand getan hat, glaube ich.
Das heißt, die neuen Fintech-Firmen bauen jetzt gerade alle Web-Scrape?
Noch dazu, ja, genau.
Das ist so absurd alles.
Und sind dann berechtigt, die zu benutzen, wenn der andere Kram kaputt geht?
Und ich habe immer noch nicht so genau verstanden, was der Sinn von der ganzen Sache ist.
Den existierenden Markt weiterlaufen zu lassen?
Also ja, ich verstehe, dass das sozusagen der ökonomische Hintergrund ist. Aber manchmal hast du ja bei Gesetze und Rechtsdienste sozusagen so eine Idee, die zumindest so klingt, als würde das die Welt irgendwie besser machen oder Dinge für Kunden sicherer oder irgendwie sowas.
Das klingt halt auch noch mehr Sicherheit. Man muss ja mehr Sachen tun, aber mehr Sachen tun heißt nicht immer mehr Sicherheit.
Ich bin total verwirrt, weil wir reden jetzt schon ganz lange über dieses Ding und das läuft sich aber irgendwie so tot. Also ich hab jetzt gelernt, es gibt jetzt mehr Beteiligte, das ist alles ein bisschen umständlicher. Da müssen mehr Tanz eingegeben werden, was die Sache nicht unbedingt sicherer macht, sondern vielleicht sogar das Gegenteil, man weiß es nicht so genau. Und es gibt auch keinen, der so richtig krass davon profitiert. Also ja, vielleicht PayPal, man weiß es nicht so genau. Es gibt jetzt diese, man kann vielleicht mehr Daten abgreifen mit Bankverkehr. Aber das wirkt alles so wie so ein Gummi-Watte-Ding, was eigentlich keinen richtigen Sinn hat, aber das Leben generell ein bisschen schwerer macht.
Genau, also an einigen Stellen ein bisschen schwerer, an einigen Stellen sehr viel schwerer.
Vielleicht wird das mit der PSD3 irgendwann nochmal besser.
Wann kommt die? Die PSD2 hat eine Regelung drin, dass die Richtlinie spätestens zwei Jahre nach dem Krafttreten überprüft werden muss. Also überprüft im Sinne von gucken wir, ob wir was ändern wollen.
Dann wird also eine Arbeitsgruppe gegründet?
Ja, 2021 ist glaube ich die erste Überprüfung dran. Ja, also was ich mir halt wünschen würde, wäre eine Verpflichtung, auch die Möglichkeit, einen Endkunden direkt. Also so ein, ja ja, will ich zulassen, Knopf. So was wie folgende Software möchte darauf zugreifen, ja will ich.
Was mich halt stutzig gemacht hat, ich hab halt mit diesem zentralen Kredit-Ausschuss da per E-Mail kommuniziert.
Die heißt jetzt übrigens die Deutsche Kreditwirtschaft.
Ob ich als Privatperson, die ein Skript für mein eigenes Konto schreiben möchte, auch diese Registrierung brauche und so. Meins ja, ja, auf jeden Fall. Aber ich solle ja glücklich sein, sie hätten einen sehr einfachen Weg dafür geschaffen. Ich müsste jetzt kein Zertifikat holen, ich muss nur diese ID holen. Und das sei derzeit ja auch noch kostenlos. Also derzeit.
Ist das, weil du vorhin auch Open Source Entwickler gesagt hast, das trocknet diesen Markt doch auch. Also weil in dem Moment, wo ich für den Betrieb einer solchen Software diese Geheimnisse haben müsste, was ich nicht darf, oder sehr aufwendig selber beantragen müsste, ist das ja eigentlich sozusagen ein Bereich, wo man, ich formuliere es mal, ein bisschen drastisch Innovationen unterbindet, weil jetzt nicht jeder sich hinsetzen kann und sagen kann, hey, ich würde jetzt gerne eine Schnittstelle für die Bank irgendwie schreiben, weil mal gucken, vielleicht kriege ich einfach eine Software für die Steuerberechnung viel besser als alle anderen. Das geht jetzt einfach nicht mehr, oder geht schon. Ich muss dann halt nur über einen Drittanbieter gehen.
Genau, das war vorher ein Musterbeispiel für permissionless innovation. Jeder konnte sich hinsetzen und Dinge tun. Spezifikation war frei im Internet herunterzuladen. Und jetzt hast du halt allerlei regulatorische Hürden, die du nehmen musst, bevor du überhaupt anfangen kannst, darüber nachzudenken, was zu tun.
Ich bin mir immer noch nicht ganz sicher, ob das nicht vielleicht doch eine gute Idee ist. Weil ich mich anders doch wieder frage, wenn aber jeder irgendwie Software schreiben darf, die man gegen das Bankensystem werfen kann, ist denn das so gut?
Ja, du musst dir in jedem Fall eine Benutzer- Identifizierung durchführen. Du musst dir in jedem Fall ein Benutzer sagen, ja, das soll auf mein Konto zugreifen. Und ja, es gibt dann auch doofe Benutzer, aber man muss ja nicht, ne?
Man kann sozusagen nicht mit Vorsatz missbrauchen, weil man braucht halt immer... Ich komm wirklich auf keinen Grün... Also das Ding ist, ich hab nichts... Ich komme zu keinem Fazit. Also normalerweise hat man sowas, Technologie doof anzünden, wegschmeißen. Das würde ja nicht gehen.
Ja, wegschmeißen geht halt leider nicht.
Es ist halt so ein bisschen... Also es ist auch nicht so richtig schlimm. Es ist halt so ein bisschen nervig und natürlich doof, wenn man das anders gewohnt ist. Es gibt aber jetzt auch keinen kleinen Ausblick. Oder gibt es das? Gibt es jetzt eine politische Forderung, dass man sagt, so pass mal auf Leute, in zwei Jahren PSD3, da muss Folgendes drin sein.
Weiß ich nicht. Ob es lobbytechnisch so ist, dass wie gesagt, bei meinem Vortrag hatte sich jemand gemeldet von der Sofort GmbH, die meinten, die finden das auch gerade nicht so gut. Ich hoffe also, dass die auch noch...
Die Banken sind auch nicht glücklich.
Genau, Banken sind totunglücklich. Naja, die müssen A, diesen Implementierungsscheiß machen, den sie bisher nicht hatten. Dann haben sie die ganzen Kundenbeschwerden.
Also okay, ich musste mal den DSG-VO-Vergleich raus. Weil auch eine EU-Richtlinie, auch lange Vorlaufzeit, auch irgendwie super komplex. Da gibt es ja immerhin die Datenschützer, die sagen, geile Sache, Datenschutz bewirkt was, wir verhängen jetzt Bußgelder, yeah, yeah, yeah. Kann man auch alles drüber streiten, aber es gibt Leute, die sind davon wirklich ernsthaft begeistert.
Es gibt gute Teile in der PSD2. Das, worüber wir diskutiert haben, waren der Dienstleisterkram und die Kundenautentifizierung.
Warte, dann gleich das. Aber vorher noch, gibt es jemanden, der davon total begeistert ist? Der sagt, geile Sache, PSD2 super.
Den Kundenkram nicht, nee. Leute, die Software entwickeln, die den Scheiß umsetzen, ja okay.
Ich würde Berater immer ausnehmen.
Aha, nee, aber ich hatte mal ein Meeting, wo es um was anderes ging bei der Bundesbank.
Das war jetzt nicht Gegenwart, aber wenn du ein Ding machst, wo nur Leute, das ist so ein bisschen wie Ärzte dafür bezahlen, nicht, dass sie sich darum kümmern, sondern, dass sie möglichst viele Ressourcen haben.
Ich hatte mal ein Meeting bei der Bundesbank, da sprachen die, die finden ganz toll, dass es jetzt neue Berichtspflichten gibt. PSD2 macht ja alle möglichen Kram, unter anderem steht da halt auch drin, dass jeder nach Zahlungsdienstleister, also die Oberkategorie, nicht nur Konfirmations- und Zahlungsauslüsendienste, jeder Zahlungsdienstleister verpflichtet ist, folgende Arten von Betrugsfällen und so weiter weiter nach oben zu melden, damit die ein besseres Bild über den Finanzmarkt und die Stabilität des Finanzmarktes haben.
Nur nach oben oder auch nach außen?
Na ja, oben in dem Sinne meine ich also in Deutschland BaFin bzw. wer auch mal dafür zuständig ist.
Ja, aber trotzdem auch da die Frage.
Die behandeln das privat, also...
Was es vielleicht software-technisch besser macht, ist, dass diese APIs jetzt moderner werden. Und wir nicht mehr irgendwie wie bei HBCI irgendwie ein seilenbasiertes, Großbankenrechner-systemartiges Protokoll haben, was Space64 kodiert in HTTPS-Requests reingeschrieben wird.
Du benutzt jetzt gerade sehr viele Fremdworte, die ich jetzt nicht alle nachtrage, aber ich gehe davon aus sozusagen, dass Modernisierung stattfindet, aber es doch zum Preis, dass man nicht drauf zugreifen kann.
Genau, du kannst halt auf die PSD2-API nicht zugreifen. Und auch HBCI gab es ja in XML, das ist auch schon 2002 oder so standardisiert worden, hat nie jemand benutzt. Nein, das ist nicht ganz richtig. In der Bankenliste ist genau eine Bank drin, die HBCI 4, also Fintes 4.0 angibt. Also modern hätte man auch anders haben können.
Aber was sind denn die Vorteile, die du gerade meintest, es gibt auch gute Sachen?
Das ist die Berichtspflichten und die Transparenz für den Endkunden. Also der Endkunde soll jetzt, und das ist auch bei einigen Banken ganz gut umgesetzt, genauer sehen, wer Zugang auf sein Konto hat. Also von Bankseite aus.
Wer da sozusagen mal geguckt hat, was da so geht.
Genau.
Das heißt also die dritten Bank Cloud Dienstleister, die stehen da.
Die stehen da und auch ich als Open Source Entwickler, der meine Software gegen mein eigenes Konto geworfen hat, wird da meine Software aufgelistet.
Ja gut, aber das ist, also von allem, was ich heute gehört habe, das ist nice, aber wiegt den Rest nicht so richtig auf, würde ich sagen.
Ja, das ist halt nicht sicher. Also.
Es ist nicht was?
Jedenfalls dann nicht, wenn du über Fintes gehst.
Na, man könnte falschen, welcher Anbieter da auftaucht.
Genau, also diese ID, die ich da beantragen muss, ist halt wirklich nur ein Text-String. Und da kann ich auch irgendwas anderes angeben. Und dann steht eine andere Software da. Das ist also völlig für den...
Ja gut, aber das ist halt, wie gesagt, erst nach Eingabe der Kunden-Pin, deswegen ist ein bisschen egal. Also du kannst eine Software ausführen auf deinem Rechner, die sich dort anmeldet, mit deinen Benutzerdaten, und dann sich das als eine andere Software angibt, wenn du auf deinem Konto nachguckst, wer zugegriffen hat.
Okay.
Dass ich aber als Phishing-Attacke und ähnliches natürlich auch super nehmen kann.
Aber, also es gibt auch Angriffe, aber es ist schon... Moment mal, reden wir jetzt aus Prinzip schlecht?
Ich nicht. Ich fand das ganz gut. Ich hab mich da als Entwickler registriert und war dann ganz kurz. Hat den Vorteil, ich krieg jetzt auch die Bankenliste. Das war vorher immer ein bisschen anstrengend.
Ja, die Bankenliste, die...
Die Liste aller Banken, die HBCI Zugänge haben.
Na gut. Ich verbleibe mal mit einem... Haben wir noch was vergessen?
Die fünf Minuten sind tatsächlich aus der PSD2. Aha! Das sind halt verschiedene Zeitdinger. Also da steht, oder aus dem Anhang RTS, da stehen halt verschiedene Dinge drin. Das ist einmal halt diese Tanz. Das sind die 90 Tage, außer manchmal, unter Umständen oder vielleicht. Tatsächlich ist die Formulierung so, dass die Anmeldung mit starker Kundeautentifizierung entfallen kann, wenn kein Zugriff auf Kontoinformationen älter als 90 Tage möglich ist.
Also wenn ich vorher schon mal war.
Zum Beispiel innerhalb der letzten 90 Tage eine TAN eingegeben hast oder, du kannst ja immer eine Liste von Buchungen angucken, dann kannst du ja sagen, welchen Zeitraum. Wenn du da einen Zeitraum größer 90 Tage eingibst, dann musst du plötzlich für diese Ansicht eine TAN eingegeben. Das ist der Grund, den du am Anfang erwähnt hast mit der DKB. Banken können das unterschiedlich implementieren. Die Sparkasse macht das so, dass du dich einfach anmelden kannst und alle 90 Tage eine TAN brauchst. Die DKB macht das so, dass du bei jeder Anmeldung eine TAN brauchst. Dafür dann aber innerhalb des Interfaces mehr als 90 Tage sehen darfst.
Bei meiner Bank ist das so, wenn ich mich anmelde, dann fragt die gar nicht nach einer TAN, sondern sagt, guck mal bitte auf dein Handy. Genau. Dann geht da die Online-Banking-App auf und da ist nur ein Knopf, ich soll es bestätigen. Keine Abfrage von nichts.
Genau, das ist das, was ich meine. Also TAN ist jetzt als Platzhalter zu verstehen. Starke Kundenautentifizierung sagt, dass du zwei von den drei Kategorien Besitz, Inherenz und Wissen haben musst. Besitz ist Besitz des Telefons. Inherenz ist zum Beispiel Face-ID oder Fingerabdruck. Und Wissen ist Kenntnis der PIN.
Ach so, ich weiß sowieso die PIN.
Du hast die PIN eingegeben auf der Webseite. Und du hast Telefon...
Ich hab mein Handy entsperrt.
Mit Gesicht entsperrt. Nein, ohne Biometrie.
Nimm das.
Oder zumindest besitzt das Telefon zu nachgewiesen. Und deswegen sind das schon zwei Faktoren erfüllt. Auf welchem Mechanismus die Bank feststellt, dass das der Fall ist, dann ist ja nur der einfachste Mechanismus. Also technisch gesehen der einfachste Mechanismus. Die können ja auch Kommunikation hinten rum und das Telefon sagt der Bank Bescheid, dass alles okay ist. Und dann sind halt noch die 5 Minuten drin. Also die neuerdings... Früher bei der Sparkasse waren es immer 12 Minuten. Neuerdings steht da halt auch drin, dass nach 5 Minuten ohne Aktivität wieder ausgelockt werden muss.
Woher kommen eigentlich diese 5 Minuten?
Völlig unklar. Steht da einfach als Zahl drin.
Niemand weiß sich wo...
Man weiß es nicht.
Also weil... Auch wenn es total nervig wäre, 30 Sekunden könnte ich verstehen. Das ist halt so ein Todmannschalter. Nur wenn du wirklich vom Rechner bist, bist du eingelockt. Viertelstunde könnte ich auch verstehen. Okay, anscheinend hast du keinen Bock mehr. Wir locken dich mal aus. Aber 5 Minuten? Das ist so die Maximale... Jemand setzt sich hin und sagt so, Leute, wie ist denn das? Also welche Zahl? Die grauen Herren Momo-Stylen. Welche Zeit können wir nehmen, die maximal nervig ist? Also wo man uns nicht so einen Vorwurf machen kann, aber die so echt unfassbar anstrengend ist.
Wir nehmen die Durchschnittszeit und subtrechen eine Minute.
Mutags hat jetzt gerade im Chat geschrieben DKB und Cloudflare und DDoS-Attacke. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir das jetzt noch besprechen sollten. Das hört sich für mich nach einem ganz anderen Thema an.
Hat auch mit der PSD2 erstmal nichts zu tun. Das ist ein bisschen DSGVO, ein bisschen BaFin.
Dann hält man uns das, glaube ich, für ein anderes Mal auf. Ich habe noch eine ganz praktische Frage zum Schluss. Und zwar, weil wir jetzt auch darüber geredet haben, dritte Parteien und irgendwie Daten fallen da an. Man will das ja alles nicht. Und PayPal sowieso, weil auch eine Ami ist da. So, folgendes Szenario. Ich kaufe etwas online. So hat er die ganze Szenario auch angefangen. Ich kaufe etwas online. Und der Anbieter gibt mir verschiedene Zahlungsmöglichkeiten. Und da steht sofort Überweisung. Ich so, nee, nee, das will ich ja nicht. Das finde ich, das riecht irgendwie. Das will ich nicht so. Dann steht da PayPal. Ich so, nee, das will ich auch nicht. Das ist doof. Und dann steht da Kreditkarte. Und dann denke ich so, naja. Nee, auch nicht so gern. Das wäre auch wieder so eine dritte Firma. Und dann Lastrift. Okay, Lastrift, geil. Klicke Lastrift. Geht eine Seite auf. Hier, PayPal, ohne einloggen. Kannst du Lastrift auf dein Bankkonto machen? Ich so, na, das will ich lieber nicht.
Okay, also Lastrift ist tatsächlich das Bevorzug über Waren. Manche wickeln das über PayPal ab, aber ich hab das auch selten gesehen. Das ist, glaub ich, nicht mehr üblich.
Das kann gut sein.
Ich hab das auch häufiger mal benutzt. Und dann hat PayPal irgendwann gesagt, du bist jetzt aber schon zum 5. Mal mit dieser Konto-Nummer bei Lastrift dabei. Jetzt legst du aber bitte ein Konto an.
Dann gibt es auch Kreditkarte, kann man dann auch klicken. Und dann machen wir über PayPal. Meine Frage jetzt, und das ist sozusagen nicht politisch, sondern wirklich ganz praktikabel. Man hat jetzt also die Wahl zwischen Pest oder Cholera, nehme ich entweder PayPal oder Sofortüberweisung. Welches würde man dann nehmen? Also ich meine, nicht einkaufen oder Vorkasse immer auch Option, weiß ich. Aber es ist ganz dringend, man hat dieses neue Produkt gesehen und muss das unbedingt jetzt kaufen. Und hat dann nur noch die Wahl zwischen den beiden. Mutags, was würdest du machen? Würfeln.
Tatsächlich Paypal, weil ich da zumindest nicht gegen die AGB von meiner Bank verstoße.
Dank PSD2 ist Sofortüberweisung jetzt auch gut. Okay, du würdest würfeln. Du musst aber wenigstens noch sagen, wäre Paypal gerade oder ungerade auf deinem Würfel?
Ja.
Ach so.
Also du hörst, das ist sehr gequält. Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Wie würdest du dich entscheiden, Henrik?
Es kommt ein bisschen darauf an, auch den Geldbetrag. Weil bei kleineren Summen ist Paypal zumindest okay, wenn man sowieso schon an anderen Stellen gezwungen wurde, ein Konto zu eröffnen. Umgekehrt sitzt Paypal gerne auf Rücküberweisungen. Wenn irgendwas schief geht, landet das Geld erstmal wieder bei Paypal. Und die haben manchmal nicht Lust, das auszuzahlen, sondern sagen sich, das ist jetzt aber komisch. Das sperren wir jetzt mal für 180 Tage und gucken mal, ob sich jemand beschwert. Und dann lieber gleich die Direktkreditkartenoption.
Die läuft ja auch über Paypal.
Ja, kann man gegebenenfalls noch mehr tun. Also, sofort Überweisung würde ich weitestgehend rauslassen.
Okay, also die nur, wenn es wirklich gar nicht mehr anders geht.
Ja.
Okay, na gut, das ist doch eine klare Ansage, da kann ich arbeiten. So, dann, glaub ich, brauchen wir noch was? Gibt es noch Fragen?
Fragen aus dem Publikum?
Nein, keine Fragen. Gut, dann würde ich sagen, beschließen wir die Runde für heute. Ich habe gelernt, dass es EU-Richtlinien gibt, die nicht viel besser machen, aber dafür sehr problematisch sind. Toll, vielen Dank.
Na, haben wir was gekonnt.
Ja, haben wir was gekonnt. Ich bin gespannt, ob wir uns dann zu PSD3 wieder treffen. Mutags, vielen Dank, dass du dabei warst. Aus Usarbrücken. Und bitte nicht mehr so viel Frust beim Überweisen. Schick mir einfach all dein Geld, ich kümmere mich darum. Das ist gar kein Problem. Henrik, vielen Dank dir auch fürs ausführliche Erklären. Genau, man kann dieses Chaosradio hören. Wir schreiben dir schon auch noch ein paar Links. Und wenn man es nochmal ausführlicher wissen will, auch nochmal deinen Vortrag gucken vom 36C3. Apropos Vortrag Chaos Communication Congress. Vom 34C3 gab es noch einen über das... Die wunderbare Welt des Online Banking, wo mal genau geguckt wurde, was man da machen konnte. So, wir sind dann raus. Wir hören gleich noch eine letzte Musik. Ich sage aber jetzt erstmal, mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Lasst sie nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure geo-redundanten Backups.